In this course you will improve your JavaScript
skills by building a shopping cart in JavaScript
with no frameworks, joi teaches this course,
Joy works at Free Code Camp, and he is excellent
at breaking down concepts for beginners, be
sure to leave a comment with something you
learned in this course. Hey guys, j here.
Today we're going to learn how to make a shopping
cart just using vanilla JavaScript. So guys,
this is a project that we're going to make
today. As you can see that this is a clothing
store. And we have in row 12 items to sell.
Every product card will have an image, a title,
some dummy description, price, and these options.
So what are these options? These options will
help you to specify how much quantity Do you
want of this specific product, let's say that
you want 15 pieces of this specific product.
So you're gonna increase the quantity here
by this look at this, I'm making it 15. Or
let's say that I want to decrease the quantity,
I can decrease the quantity here like this.
Okay, so guys, whatever product you select,
you can always see the numbers updating here
itself. Let me show you a sample. Okay, let's
say that I want to increase the quantity of
this t shirt by six. Okay, and I want to increase
the quantity of the suit by seven, then you
can see that this number is updating itself
automatically. And do you see these numbers
here? 4567? What are these? These are your
selections, these are your data. Even if you
refresh the page, this data will not get erased.
How is this possible? In JavaScript, there's
a feature called local storage, throw that
feature, you can save all of your data inside
the browser. By that even if you refresh the
page, the data will never get erased. So we're
going to learn how to implement local storage
inside our project. And guys look at this,
if I click on this basket here, then you can
see all of your selected products that you
selected from the shop page. So here we are
going to get the thumbnail of the product
that we selected, we can get the quantity
button here, the unit price is here. Along
with that we have this number. So what is
this actually, so how is this calculated,
this is calculated by multiplying the unit
price by the total quantity, which is five
times 100 is 500. Just like that, all the
cards will do all of its calculations. And
once all of these things are done, you can
see the total bill here like this, let's say
that you want to increase the office shirt
by 10, you can increase it here like that.
And you can see that this number updates itself.
And this tool will also update this itself,
you can also decrease it like this, there
we go. And let's say that you don't want this
thing entirely. So what you can do is you
can just click on this cross, and it's gonna
remove itself automatically like that. So
it's gonna work just like that. The source
code of today's project is in my GitHub repository
link will be provided in the description down
below. So once you enter the link, you can
see that we have three branches in total.
Okay, if I click on here, then you can see
that we have the main branch product images
and the starter files. So what we're going
to do is we're going to download the starter
files and start our project. The finalized
project will be here on the main and what
are these product images? Let me show you.
If I click on here, then you can find the
all the 12 images here. Let me show you. Do
you see this one here? We have all the product
images here. And if I go back on the data
Jas. So what is this data? Yes, it carries
all the data of our product cards. Let me
show you a sample. Okay. So if I go back to
the store, do you see this data here? Yeah,
all of this data are actually stored inside
this data. Yes, guys, don't worry, because
along the video, I'm going to teach you how
to utilize these resources. So let's start
our main tutorial. Alright guys, before starting
a tutorial, first of all, we need to set up
our environment. To do that, you're gonna
right click, create a new folder, okay. And
then you can name it anything you wish, but
for this tutorial, I'm going to name it shopping
cart, okay, shopping minus cart, something
like this, okay, and then we're going to right
click open with VS code, okay, if you don't
have this option, don't worry, just come over
to the search bar. And then you just hit VS
code manually. So once it opens, you're going
to come to File Open folder like this, okay,
then come over to your desktop, and then search
for the folder that you created, which is
this one shopping cart open. Okay, and then
you can see your project folder, we're getting
open in VS code. The source code of this project
is in my GitHub repository, I'm going to provide
the link of this repository in the description
down below. So once you click on the link,
you're going to come over here and you're
going to find all the files and folders. Like
look at this. We have the images folder here
you see we did this one. For that you just
click on the code, then download zip is gonna
get downloaded in a zip format. Then you're
gonna open the zip like this, then come over
to your desktop, and then extract the file
like this look. Okay, then we're gonna open
this folder and vs images here. We're going
to drag it outside. Okay, next up, let's close
this one and then we get the images inside
our source folder like this. By the way, guys,
this folder carries all the solutions, okay,
I don't need it. But if you want to keep it
If you want to check it out here, no problem.
So I'm going to delete that. Alright guys,
let's go back to our VS code here and you're
going to see this images folder you see, I'm
going to open up this one. Initially, you're
going to get four images. Don't worry guys,
I'm going to add more images to this folder.
But for now, we're just gonna work with four
images. Let's open up this okay? And then
you're gonna find pictures of shirts, T shirts,
formal shirts, etc. Okay, you also get a suit
here. By the way, guys, you might have a question
like, where did I get these images from? Okay,
I got it from two websites. First one is unsplash.com.
And another one is called pixels.com. Okay,
so you can go to any website, and then you
right here shirt, okay, enter, then you're
going to find images of shirts, formal shirts,
casual shirts, pants, shoes, etc. If you scroll
down, then do you see this image here? I took
it from where unsplash.com. So you can find
that that same image on the folder, you see.
So I really hope you understood how I got
these images from and you can also use the
same resources to do your own personal projects.
Okay. Okay, guys, let's come back to VS code.
And now we're going to create three files.
Okay. So first one will be index html, okay,
index dot HTML, then style of CSS. And finally,
main.js. Okay. There we go. All right. Okay,
guys, let's come back to our index html and
make boilerplate code to do that you're going
to hit exclamatory sign, then you're going
to find this option. If you don't find the
option, then do this. You hit control space
together, and then you're going to find Emmet
here. So if you click on this one, the boilerplate
code will automatically generated this is
called Emmet plugin of vs. Code. Okay. And
on the title we can right here clothing store,
okay, since this is a clothing store website,
okay, something like this. There we go. One
second. Okay, perfect. Now, do you see the
style css? I'm going to link it here like
this? Look, Li N K. Listen, if you don't find
this option, okay, do this. Okay, you're going
to hit control space together like this. And
then you're going to find Emmet abbreviation,
you just click on this one. There, we can
see that the code got automatically written.
So you don't have to write style css manually
in the href. Do these guys, you just hit Ctrl
Space together? Can you see this path here?
All of them are automatically shown up here.
You just click on style css, there you go.
I saved your time. Okay, using Emmet. So now
you're going to come here, do you see these
two tags here ending tags, you just come here
and write SC. Again, if you don't find the
option like this, you just hit control space
to get there. And then you're going to select
this option. Okay? And on the source, you're
going to come here and then write control
space. Okay, and then select this one. Do
you see this main? Yes. Click on it like this.
There we go. Save it. Next up, come over to
the body and let's write some sample text.
Okay, so let's write hello, world, something
like this. There we go. Alright, guys, now
we're going to use a plug in called live server.
If you don't have it, just come over here.
And then right here, live server, something
like this. Let me zoom in. Okay, so do you
see this one here, live server made my home
Ritwik. They just come over here and install
the thing. Once you install a live server,
then you're going to come back to your HTML,
okay? And then you're going to right click
here and then you're going to find option
called Open with live server. Okay. By the
way, there is also an alternative. Can you
see this one here? On this ribbon, this blue
color ribbon, you also get the option here
it is called go live. If you click on this
one, then that project will get opened in
your web browser something like this. Do you
see this Hello World here. Let me zoom in.
In order to zoom in, you just hit Ctrl. And
then you scroll your mouse wheel like this.
Can you see this one? You can just zoom in
and zoom out like this. There we go. Okay,
guys, can you see this gap here? Okay, do
you ever default styles of your browser, so
we need to remove those default styles of
the browser? In order to do that. Let's go
back to your CSS. Okay, so you're gonna write
a star, curly bracket, okay, m zero tab. There
we go. Here's what just Emmet. Then you're
gonna hit P zero tab. There we go. You see.
Next time you're going to write in a box sizing
border box, something like this. Save it.
Let's look at the result. Can you see that
the gaps are gone. Okay. And do you see this
font here we are pleased the font family.
In order to replace the font family just come
over here and then right body. Okay, curly
bracket. Now FF tab. Now you're going to remove
this save and write S S. If you don't see
the option, then do this. You're going to
hit Control Space sans save, enter. Done.
Okay, save it. So now let's look at the result.
Can you see that the font family of our fonts
changed. Alright guys, so far, so good. We're
done setting up our VS Code project folder.
Now we're going to start coding. So the very
first thing that we're going to build is this
navbar Do you see this navbar here Let's build
it up first of all, okay to do that, let's
come back to our VS code here. Okay guys come
over to your index html and then scroll down
to your body section here. Let's remove the
Hello World, we don't need it. We're going
to also use Emmet here to write HTML markup
quickly follow along with me, okay, we're
gonna hit dot nav bar tab. If you don't find
the option, same solution, just hit control
space together, then you're going to find
the option. Okay, then hit tab. There we go.
That's how we're going to save time using
which plugin the plugins name is called Emmet.
Okay, you can see that Emmet automatically
wrote me a div with the class name navbar.
Brilliant. Okay, guys, let's come inside the
nav bar. And now we're going to hit h2 Tap.
There we go. So this will carry our brand
logo name. You can write anything you wish,
but I'm gonna write here clothing store. Okay.
Clothing Store. There we go. Done. So this
is the result. So far, we only have our brand
logo name here. Okay, guys, let's come back
to the Finalize project. Do you see this shopping
cart icon here, we're going to make this one
at the same time. Do you see this dark background
color, we're going to apply this dark background
color to our nav bar as well. So let's come
back to our VS code here. Okay. And below
the h2 tag, we're going to make another div
with the class name card. Look at this dot
card, tap. There we go. Now inside here, we're
going to have icon and after the icon, we're
going to have another div with the class name
card amount. Look at this dot card. Mo. Okay,
something like this. There we go. And now
inside here, we're going to write zero. Okay,
so why did they actually write the zero? Let
me actually show you. So if you compare the
thing with the file as project, do you see
this one here? We have a number here. This
is 47. Initially, there's going to be zero.
That's why I wrote the zero. And for the icon,
where will I get the icon from? I'm going
to use a website called icons dot get bootstrap.com.
Okay, so if you come over here, then if you
scroll up, you're going to find a tons of
icons here. So for our project, we're going
to right here cart like this. And now if you
scroll down, you're going to find a lot of
options. Do you see this one here? We have
a lot of options. So let's pick any one of
them. But before picking any one of them,
just scroll down. And you're going to find
the CDN. Can I see the CDN here, just copy
the CDN. Okay, now let's come back to our
index html, and then you just paste it inside
the headlight this save it done. Now we can
freely use a CDN for icons, let's scroll up.
So I'm going to use I don't know, but let
me just pick this one. Or let's pick this
one. Okay. Now you're going to scroll down
and you're going to find this called Icon
font. Just copy the thing. Let's go back to
our VS code. And now do you see this one?
Before the cart amount? This one, okay, just
paste the thing here. Save it done. Let's
look at the result. Okay, so you have let
me just zoom in a little bit. Do you see this
one here. This is the brand logo name. This
is our shopping cart icon. And this is our
zero here. Alright, so now we're going to
style the thing. And for the color, guys for
the background color. Do you see this dark
background color? Where did they get the color
from? Let me show you. I got it from coolers.co.
This is one here coolers.co. I got it from
here. So how you're going to use the thing
you just come over to explore trending palettes
like this. Okay, next up, I just want you
to search and then I just picked on the black
like this. Then if you scroll down, then you're
going to find tons of color palettes I use
this color can see this one here to one to
five to nine I use this one. So I'm just gonna
copy up this one. And then let's go back to
our VS code. Guys, we're done writing the
HTML markup for our navbar component. Okay,
so just copy up the class name. And let's
go back to our style css and at the bottom
here, you just write dot faced curly rec.
Okay, so why did it write the dot? Because
if you come back to HTML, do you see this
one here? This is the class, okay? If the
thing is a class, then you go write a dot.
But it's an ID as an example, let me just
write your ID. Okay, nav bar. So if the thing
is an id like this, then you have to select
the thing by writing a hashtag hashtag nav
bar, then curly bracket. So I really hope
you understood the difference between selecting
a ID and class inside your CSS. Okay, let's
remove that one. Let's come back to ourselves.
CSS remove this one. So we're gonna keep a
dot navbar. Okay, next time we're gonna write
a background color. Okay, easily write this
BGC tab. There we go. Do you see that hashtag
FFF. Let's remove that and paste the color
that we copied. So I'm going to make it 212.
Okay, 529529 Save it. Let's look at the result.
So if we go back here, you see everything
is complete dark, we can't see anything. So
in order to see something, let's go back here
and change the font color. Okay, so to do
that, you just right here color, sorry, color,
like this. And then right here, White. Done.
Let's look at the results. You see, we have
the results so far. All right, guess let's
go back here and apply some padding. Okay?
So P tab, so you're gonna right here 25 pixel,
and then 60 pixel. So why they give two values
here? Let me explain the 25 pixel, you see,
this is the value for the top and bottom.
And the 60 pixels is the value for the left
and right. So padding top and bottom will
be how much 25 pixels and padding left and
right will be 60 pixels. Okay, let me show
you the result. If you come back here to do
you see this value here, this is how much
is 60 pixels here, this is 25 pixel here,
25 pixels here, and there will be 60 pixels
here as well. So I really hope you understood
how I applied the padding. Okay? All right,
guys, our shopping cart icon looks like this.
But we want it to look like this. Can you
see this one here? So let's go and style this
thing. Okay, so let's go back to our VS code,
by the way, guys, is also a very good thing
to write comments. So in order to write nice
comments on our code, let me show you a new
thing. Okay, you just come to the extensions.
And right here better comment. Okay, better
comment, like this. And now you're going to
find this Kanji this one here better comment
written by Aaron Boone. Just click on this
one and then install the thing. So let me
show you the cool feature using this extension.
Okay. So you can just write beautiful, colorful
comments, let me show you. So if you right,
slash star star, enter, okay, star and then
star star slash, if you come here, and if
you right here exclamatory sign, then you
can see that your comment is now red color.
Do you see that? So I'm just gonna use the
plugin. I also recommend you use the same
plugin, which is called Better comment written
by Aaron ponte. Okay. So once you install
a thing, you just come over here and let me
show it to you. Again, you just see right
here, slash star star, okay, enter star and
then star star slash again. Okay? So if you
hit exclamatory sign like this is going to
be in red color. And if you hit question mark
like this, then it's going to be in blue color.
Can you see that? So you have a lot of options.
So I'm gonna use the red color, okay, something
like this. And then here, I'm gonna write
changing default styles of the browser, okay?
Something like this. All right. And now I'm
going to scroll down here in this section,
I'm going to make another comment. So let
me just copy, copy this thing from there and
then put it here. And then here, I'm going
to write nav bar style, sir here, nav bar
styles are here, something like this. There
we go. Okay. Alright, guys, our task right
now is to make the Shopping Cart icon with
a number indicator. Okay, but look at our
results. So far. We have the icon and the
number here, we want this thing to be on the
very right side, how do we do it? We do it
by using a property called Flexbox. Okay,
so let's go back to our HTML, which actually
here Okay, so here's the rule, the very first
rule of using Flexbox is you have to use Flexbox
inside the parent selector. In our cases,
look at this one. Can you see this one here?
This is the main parent, okay. And this one
will be the children. This is also another
children. So how many children do you have?
You have two children inside this parent?
Okay, so let's target this one inside CSS.
It is already targeted here. So just come
here and write d f, tab. Okay, display flex.
Next up. If you save it, then you can see
some result. Look at this. Can you see this
one here? Previously, this thing was here,
okay, now it's on the right side. That's because
the moment you enable display flex, there
is a default property called Flex direction.
Okay, so the default value of this property
is called row. That's why you saw this one.
Okay. Can you see that? But if you if you
come here, and then if you write a column,
like this, save it now look at the result
can see that this was the previous behavior,
but we want it to be in a in a format of row,
okay? That's the result so far. Okay, guys,
I'm gonna keep it here. And I'm gonna code
below. Okay, there's another property called
justify content. Okay. So in order to put
this thing and this thing apart from each
other, we're going to use that justify content
property. Follow along with me, JC JC stands
for justify content. SB means space between
tab. Okay, save it. There we go. Can see that.
Now, this is here and our icon is on the very
right side. So far, so good. Okay. Now we're
going to style our icon here. So let's get
started. First of all, let's go to our HTML
Okay, to inspect the structure. Look at this.
Okay, guys, this is our cart here. And inside
this cart, we have two children. Okay, this
is the icon and this one is the cart amount,
which indicates how many things you have on
your basket. It is zero at the moment. Okay,
so we're going to style this. So let's just
copy this one. Come over to style css and
at the bottom here, dot paste curly bracket.
Okay, now we're gonna style this element.
First things first, let's set the background
color to white. Okay, VGC tap Done. Okay,
and then we're gonna set the color Have to
black. Something like this look not black
actually, did you remember that we use this
color from coolers. Dotco. We're going to
use this color. Okay, done. Okay, done. Now
let's save this thing and then let's look
at the results. Okay, so guys look at this
the results so far, let me zoom in a little
bit, okay, so that you can see it better.
There we go. Now listen, guys, the next thing
that we're going to do is we're going to increase
the font size so that so that it looks bigger,
even without zooming in like this. And then
we're going to apply some padding and border
radius. Let's go. So let's go back to our
VS code, okay, and then let's give a padding
of five pixels, okay, V five pixel, tap, done.
Okay, and then increase the font size to 30
pixels, font minus size, how much 30 pixels
done. Let's look at the result. Okay, there
we go. It became bigger. Let me just zoom
out like this. Up to 100%. There we go. It
looks much better. Okay, so now we're going
to also apply some border radius so that we
can make this juicy these corners here. We
want to make this corners rounded. Okay, let's
apply some border Yes. Like this. Look. Border
Radius, border minus radius. Okay, how much
for pixel? There we go. Save it. Let's look
at the result. Yeah, there we go. We have
this result so far. All right, guys, do you
see this zero here? I want to hang this here.
Just like our finalists project. Look at this.
Can you see this 47 Here, this is actually
hanging at the top right corner. Okay, we're
going to do the exact same styles on this
element as well. Okay, so let's get started.
So first of all, let's go back to our, what's
it called index html. Okay. And then we have
to target that element. Do you see this cart
amount here? So what is this, this is a class.
So we're going to copy this thing since it's
a class. So you're going to scroll down and
then you go right here dot paste, okay, curly
bracket, oh, sorry, curly bracket. And the
very first thing that we're going to do is
we're going to increase the font size, okay,
font minus size. Once again, font size, we're
gonna set it to how much 16 pixels. You can
use any value like here, but I'm going to
put it to 16 pixels. Next up, set the background
color to red, okay, BGC, tab, then you're
right here, red, okay, and then set the color
to white like this white. Here is it okay,
save it. Let's look at the results so far.
Okay, there we go. You see, we have the zero
here. We're just white in color, and it has
a background color of red. Alright, now we
need to hang this on the top right corner.
In order to do that, we're going to use a
property called position absolute to do this.
So I'm going to come here and then I'm alright
us abs. Okay, tab. So position absolute. Let's
look at the result. So we're going to see
this results so far. Now we need to hang this
on the top right corner. In order to do that,
look at this. You just come back here and
then right top, okay, zero. And then you're
right here, right? Oh, sorry, not inherit
is going to be zero as well say weightless
logo result. Okay, now you can notice something
odd thing is, can you see this zero here is
not on the very top right corner. The main
reason for that is wherever you apply this
position absolute Hmm. By default, by default,
this body will have a property call look at
this position relative, something like this.
That's why it behaves like this. But we don't
want this thing to behave like this. We want
the zero to be where we want the zero to be
exactly here. Okay, just like our this one,
just like the finalized project. In order
to solve this, look at this, you just come
back to a VS code versus property position
relative, you just cut it. Okay. Now scroll
down. Do you see this card here? You just
paste it here like this look. Okay, now save
it. Let's look at the result. Here is it?
There we go. Can you see that now it is working
perfectly fine. So guys, I really hope you
understood how the position relative and the
position absolute properties work. If you
don't get it don't worry, I have an entire
dedicated video can see this on here. Learn
CSS position property with examples, you can
just view this video it is just only almost
60 minutes long. Okay? Alright guys, now look
at this component here. Okay, this zero is
actually inside. We want it to be a little
bit outside at the same time, we're going
to apply some border radius and padding as
well. So let's get started. Okay, okay, guys.
So let's go back to our VS code, and I'm going
to make it a little bit smaller. Okay. And
then I'm going to keep it here. I will do
all the styles here on the cart, MO. Okay.
Okay, guys, what do I want, I want the zero
to be a little bit up and then on the right
side, in order to do that, I'm going to come
here on the top property, remove the zero
and then right minus 15 pixels, like this,
save it, then you can see the zero going a
little bit up. Okay? In the same way, if you
put here positive value like this, save it,
then I see then the zero will go down. Okay,
so I want this thing to be in negative validated,
save it. Now you can see the zero popping
up at the same time. This is right. Okay,
I'm going to adjust this as well to minus
10 pixels. Let's save it there. Look at the
result. There we go. Can you see that? It
is now shifting to the right side. Next up
guys. Let's apply some border radius and padding
as well. So p three px tap. Ok. Now guys,
you can see that the zero component became
a little bit bigger at the same time. I'm
going to apply a border Yes. Okay. Border
sorry, border radius, how much three pixel.
Okay, save it. There we go, we have the results.
So for now, guys, let's compare this with
our finalized project. Look at this, okay
can see that it is totally identical. Alright
guys, we have successfully built up our navbar
component. Now the next thing that we're going
to build is this cards. Can you see these
cards here, we're going to build this cards
to hold our image, the title, description,
price, and these buttons, which will help
us to increase the quantity and decrease the
quantity as well. So let's get started. Okay,
guys, you might have a question like, how
did I make this card layout here is very simple.
I use CSS Grid property, and then I made four
columns here, okay, in order to replicate
the same thing. What we're gonna do right
now is we're going to make a div and then
we're going to put all the cards inside there.
Let me show you how I did the thing. So you're
gonna go back to your VS code inside HTML,
okay. Do you see this nav bar, it's complete,
we're gonna fold it how to fold, put your
mouse here. Okay, then you're gonna see a
small Chevron here, just click on it. And
there you can see that your code is folded.
Perfect. Now listen, we're going to make a
div with a class name shop like this loop.sh
Opie at the same time, we're going to give
her ID as well. Hashtag shop tab. The main
reason for putting both the class and the
ID is that we're going to target this inside
CSS, and we're going to target this ID inside
JavaScript. Okay, so far. So, so far, so good
guys. Save the thing. Now listen, inside here.
One second. Let's just look at the fine, less
project. Okay. Where is it is here. So guys,
how many cards can you see here? 1234. Right.
So now look at this. Let's just come back
here. And then let's make four div with a
class names. Item. Look at this dot item,
star for tab. There we go. Okay, now let's
go back there. And let's see, what do we have?
First of all, we have image. And then do you
see all the informations on this card, we're
going to make just one div and we're going
to put all the new information inside there.
So I'm going to name this one image and this
one will be called details. Okay, let me show
you how you are going to do the thing. So
for now, I will not touch these three, I will
just work with this one. Okay, let's just
first of all, perfect only one div. Okay,
and then you can just perfect the other things
by just copy pasting the thing. Let me show
you what I mean by that. Okay, guys, inside
here, I'm going to write img tab. Okay, this
will hold my image. Don't, right, okay, just
do just put your cursor inside the source
and then hit control space, you're going to
see these images, Enter. And then we're going
to select the image number one like this,
okay, save the thing. Let's look at the result.
Okay? Okay, guys, if you look at the result,
you can see that the image is huge. Okay,
we cannot work with this image. In order to
make it smaller, just follow along with me,
okay, just come over here on your index html,
okay, this image here, just right here with
Okay, equal to double quote, just put 200
Okay, like this. Don't put pixels, just 200
as it is okay, it's still gonna work like
a pixel. Don't worry, just say the thing.
Let's look at the result. You see, the image
becomes smaller. Perfect. Next up, we're going
to pull the details. Can you see this details
here. So let's go and put those details by
coming to the HTML and below the image. We're
going to make another div with a class name
dot details. Look at this dot details. Tab.
There we go. You see, okay, guys, inside this
details, we're going to have the title tag,
the description, let me show you what we're
going to have. First of all, we're going to
have the title tag, the description, the price
and the buttons. Okay, let's make those things.
Let's just come over here and here. Inside
here, you're going to write h3 Tap. Okay,
we're gonna hit casual shirt like this. There
we go. Now below this one, we're going to
make a p tag, okay, P tab, then you're gonna
write Lorem, seven, or you can just specify
any word you like. Okay, then you're gonna
hit Tab like this. There we go. Okay, now,
guys, below this one, we're going to have
two things together. Okay, let me just show
you one thing, one second. So this is price
and the buttons, we're going to have a one
div, and inside that div, we're going to have
both the price and the buttons. Let me show
you what I mean by that. Okay, so you just
come over here and below the p tag, look at
this. We're going to right here, dot price
minus quantity, okay? Something like this.
There we go. Now, inside here, look at this
h2 tab. Here, we're going to have the price
Okay, dollar sign. 45. Okay, save it. Let's
look at the result. So you're gonna see that
$45 here now guys listening the buttons, okay?
So in order to make the buttons, look at this,
below the price, guys, you're gonna make a
deal with a cluster of buttons. look@this.bu
tt o NS tap. Okay, now guys, inside here,
we're going to use Bootstrap icons. In order
to use Bootstrap icons. You just come over
here and then you're gonna right here icons
dot get bootstrap.com Okay, this website so
guys, we're gonna use icons from this website.
Okay, now we're going to scroll down, you're
gonna see a small search bar here. Just come
here and then right plus, okay, now if we
scroll down, then you're gonna see this plus
another thing that you're gonna see is plus
LG, which is a large size. Okay, guys eat
If you didn't include the CDN link, just copy
that link, okay, then come over to your HTML
inside the head tag, okay, just come here.
And if you didn't paste it before, just paste
the thing like this. Okay, and then save it
done. Now we can freely use Bootstrap icons
into our project. Okay, let's come back here
and with large, you see this one here, I'm
going to open it in a new tab, and then I'm
going to copy the thing. Okay, let's go back
to our VS code, scroll down and this is buttons
here, inside here. I'm going to pay something
like this, save it. Okay, let's go back. And
now I'm going to get minus okay, like this
M I N U S, okay, now you're gonna see two
dash is a small one, I am in the standard
one, and this is the large one. Okay? So I'm
going to get this one like this. Okay, let's
copy the thing. Let's go back. There we go.
Now, before the plus I'm going to put the
minus Okay, there we go. Done. Now, guys,
between these two icons, you're going to have
a div with a class name and quantity. Let
me show you dot u, a n, t i t, y tab. Okay,
now you're going to play zero here, okay,
was the reason for putting a zero between
these two icons? The main reason is look is
look at this. This is a plus icon, right?
Every time you click on the plus, this number
will increment at the same time, if you use
I mean, if you click on the minus this number
will decrease. And let me show you a sample
from the finalized project. Okay, look at
this one. Do you see this one, this is the
plus icon is the quantity here and this is
the minus every time you click on this one,
the quantity increases and it shows up here.
Every time you click on this one, the quantity
decreases and it shows the result here. So
guys, I really hope that you understood why
I wrote this lines. Okay. Alright guys with
this, our markup is complete. Let's save the
thing and let's look at the result. Okay,
now this is the result. So far, it looks like
this. But don't worry, guys, we're going to
add style so that it looks like this. Okay,
the very first thing that I'm going to use
is display grid. And then we're going to make
four columns. How many columns are here, Count
with me? 1234. Okay, so let's go and make
four columns. So in order to make that, so
if you recall our Flexbox if you want to use
Flexbox, you got to apply that on a parent.
In our case, look, who is the parent, if I
fold this one like this, look at this. Okay,
who is the parent of all items? The shop is
the parent of all the items right now I'm
going to apply my display grid where inside
the shop, okay, this is class here, just copy
the thing. Hi, then come over to your style
css, then scroll down. Oh, by the way, guys,
I made a small mistake. Do you see this one
here? I wrote the font size two times. Okay.
Just remove one from here. Like save it. Okay,
now I'm gonna scroll down and make a comment.
Alright guys, before coding, first of all
listening a comment here. Okay? I mean, a
better comment with some colors. Okay, in
order to make it just right slash star star,
enter. Start, okay. exclamatory sign for red
color. Or you can use question mark for blue
color. I'm gonna use red color. Okay. exclamatory
sign then star star slash done. So here you're
gonna write a comment shop items. Styles are
here. Okay, shop. Items. Styles are here.
There we go, John. Okay. Now I'm going to
hit dot paste, curly bracket. Now inside here,
I'm going to use the very first line is display
grid. Look at this. BG tap. Okay, save it.
Let's look. Let's look at the result. You're
not gonna see any changes that let's see,
you see, we don't have any changes. Now we're
going to add more lines to it so that we can
see that changes. So guys come over here and
then right GTC tab. Okay, now guys, one second.
Let's go back to the finalized product. So
how many columns can you see here for right?
And I specify 202 and three pixels of width
for each and every one of these columns. I
mean, each and every one of these cards. We're
going to do the same thing. Look at this.
So you're going to come here and then you
got grid template columns. Repeat. Okay, so
how many columns do we need for you, right
four, comma. So how much we should each of
these columns I'm in card should be 223 pixels.
So you're gonna write it two to three. PX,
done. Okay? Save the thing. And now let's
look at the result. So if you come over here,
can you see that text? We're just outside
now This inside, okay? It's like an invisible
wall here. Okay, let me show you live one
second. So I'm just gonna keep it here. And
now look at this. I'm going to make a comment
like this. I'm gonna save it. Now. Can you
see this text actually outside? Now if you
put it here like this, save it now. There
we go. Now it feels like there's an invisible
wall. Actually, that space is getting divided.
Okay. Alright guys, so far so good. Next step
what we're going to do is use this border
here black color border. We're going to utilize
that black color border in our car. Okay,
so let's go and make that Okay, so now let's
come back to your index html. So we are done
setting up the shop. Now this item here just
copy the item okay, like this. Let's come
back to your style css scroll down and below
the shop Okay, dot paste. Now clearly record
you're gonna write here border. border to
px one second to px solid. You're gonna write
your hashtag. Do you remember the color that
we use from coolers? Dotco. Use this color.
Okay, save the thing. Let's look at the result.
Now. Can you see this thing? We have four
cards here, okay, card number 1234. Okay,
even though they don't have data, but still
they're showing up here. The main reason for
that is if you come over here on the HTML,
do you see how many days do we have here?
Four days. That's why four cards got generated
here. Okay, so if you remove anything from
here like this, save the thing. Now look at
that. You see, the cards are gone. But don't
worry, guys, we're going to generate more
cards. Okay, first of all, let's perfect only
one card. And then we can just copy paste
the other cards. Don't worry, guys. All right,
guys. Can you see the image, it looks smaller
compared to the cart border. Okay, so let's
fix that. In order to fix that just come over
to your index html. And then you're going
to open up the item. Do you see this width
here? Just if less 220 pixel like this, save
it. Now let's look at the result. There we
go. It looks perfect. Now kinases edges, it
looks sharp. We're going to make border radius.
Okay. So in our route that come back to your
style css and on it, we're going to right
here, border radius four pixel. Okay, border
does it okay border Yes, four pixels. Save
the thing. Let's look at the result. There
we go. You see now it's rounded. Our guests
Look at this. Can you see this nav bar and
this car? They don't have there is no gap
between them. Let's put some gap. Okay. Let's
come back to your style css and this is nav
bar, just right here. MB tap and then 30 pixel
legs. Okay, save the thing. There we go. Done.
Okay. Now, guys, we're going to generate three
more cards so that it looks like this. Okay,
so let's go back to your index html here.
Now just close the chevron like this, copy
the thing, and then you paste it here, then
you close the Chevron, then do the same thing
two more times, okay, like this. All right,
then save the thing. Let's load the result.
Okay. Now look at these guys, the details
doesn't look perfect, but don't worry, we're
going to style them. Okay. Now, how many cards?
Do we have four cards, there is no gap in
between them. And it is not on the center,
just like this one. In order to make those
things. What we're going to do is we're going
to go back to our style css on the shop. Where's
the shop? Here? Is it okay? This is a short
we're gonna write a gap 30 pixel legs look,
yeah, 30 pixel, say the thing, there we go
can see that we have a gap in between all
the cards. At the same time, we want them
to be on the exact center. In order. In order
to do that, just come back here and just write
it there's a property called justify content,
JC and we want the thing to be sent right.
So right JCC, tap Done. Save it. There we
go. So we have all the cards on the exact
center. Brilliant. Okay, guys. Now let's compare
the thing with our final project. Look at
this. Can you see this one here? We have a
little bit of padding here. Can you see this
one here? But we don't have padding on our
project. Okay, at the same time, do you see
this gap here? Yeah, they have a gap. But
we don't have any gap between the title tag
and the paragraph tag at the same time, this
price as well. So let's make those changes.
So in order to make the changes, come back
to your style css, and then just come back
to our index html. Okay. Open up any one of
them. I'm gonna open the first one. Okay.
Now, do you see this details here? Copy the
details. Hmm. Come back to your style css
at the bottom. Okay. Write dot paste, curly
bracket. Okay, the very first thing that we're
going to do is we're gonna right display flex
tab. There we go. Say the thing. Now, can
you see this one here? It looks odd. It looks
like a format of row. Can you see that? But
we don't want that. Because look at the finalized
project. It is in a format of column. Can
you see that? But it is actually row. So in
order to fix that, I mean, why does it happen?
That's because there's a property called Flex
direction. Once again, flex minus direction,
okay, the default value of this one is row,
every time you write this reflex, this thing
automatically gets triggered. Okay? In order
to stop that, just write display, flex direction,
and then set it to column like this. Okay,
save the thing. There we go. Perfect. Now,
guys, next time, let's apply some padding.
Okay, be 10 pixel, tap Done. There we go.
You see, this looks much better than before.
And now can you see this tag uses description
and the price. Let's put gap in between them
in order to put the gap between them. Just
come here and then right there is a political
gap property. Okay, gap 10. Pixel safe. There
we go. You see, now we have gap. Alright guys.
Now let's compare the thing with our final
project. There we go. You see, the price is
here. And all the buttons are here. But look
at our one. This is not perfect, right? So
let's fix that. In order to fix that. Let's
go back to our HTML. Okay. Now, where is the
price and the buttons? Look at this. This
is my buttons here. And this is my price.
Who is the parent? Okay, here's a question
for you. Who is the parent of this price tag
and this buttons. It's very easy guys. This
one can see this price quantity. This is the
parent of both these two tags. Okay, so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to copy
this thing like this Let us come back to our
style css at the bottom, okay, dot paste,
curly bracket. Okay. Okay guys, once this
is done inside here we're going to write display
of specs look at this DF tab. Okay? If you
save the thing now the button was actually
here now it behaves like a format of row.
Okay, why did it happen? If you recall that
I say that there is a property called Flex
direction. And every time you write this one,
the default property becomes flex direction
row something like this look, flex one second
flex direction row, okay, say the thing you
will need you will see no changes because
this is the default property already. But
if you want to change it just right column
like this, save it, you're gonna see different
results. Okay, so for this tutorial, I'm going
to use row like this say the thing there we
go. Okay, guys, next up, I want them to be
apart from each other. Okay, in order to do
that, just come here and then right JC SB
tap, okay, justify content space between,
say the thing. There we go. We have the results
so far. All right. Now, guys, we're gonna
style this icons. In order to do that. Let's
come back to our HTML. Okay, can you see these
buttons here? Yeah, this is the main parent
right now. And these are all the children's
Okay? How many children's that just does the
button have three children's. Okay, so now
let's copy this one. Let's come back here.
And now scroll down. Dot paste. Okay, curly
bracket. Now guys, if you guess that I'm going
to use display flex, you are correct. I'm
going to use display flex. Now look at this.
In which format is it in in the format of
column? Okay, we want them to be in a row
just like this one. Look at this. It is a
row format. Okay? In order to do that, just
come back here and then write df tab. Okay,
what's the default property of flex direction
here? Row? Okay, save the thing. There we
go. You see. Now even if you don't write the
display, sorry, the flex direction here. No
problem. Okay. But if you wish, then you can
right here no problem. Okay. So right, let's
right here, flex direction like this. Put
it to row. Okay, there we go. Done. Now, guys,
we need a little bit of gap in order to put
some gap just right here gap. eight pixels.
Okay, save the thing. There we go. We got
some gap. Okay. Now, if you want to set some
font size, optionally, you can do that as
well. So let's say that font size like this,
let's say 16 pixels. Okay, there we go save
the thing. Okay, you will see no changes because
guys, this is the default already already.
Okay? If you let's say right here, 26 pixel
like this, save the thing is gonna go bigger,
you see, but for this tutorial, I'm gonna
keep it six look big 16 pixels if you want
to make it bigger, sure. Best of luck. Okay,
now guys, can you see this plus and a minus?
If you notice this thing inside the Finalize
project, you can see that this is green color.
And this is red color. Okay, so in order to
do the exact same thing, just come over to
your index html, okay. Do you see this B dash
minus LG? This is a minus, okay, copy that
thing. Come over to your style css and at
the bottom, just dot paste. Okay, this is
what here's the minus right curly bracket,
then right here color. Or sorry? Color. Then
you can write your red. Okay, see the thing?
There we go. Now your minus icon is now red
color. Let's make it green. Okay, in order
to do the thing, same process, just come back
to your HTML, copy this thing. Okay. Let's
come back to your style css and the bottom
right dot paste. Okay, curly bracket. Now
you're gonna write your color. What was the
color? Green? Green. There we go. Done. Okay,
let's look at the result. Brilliant. Okay,
guys, let's draw an imaginary line. Okay,
on the x axis here, okay, if you draw an imaginary
line on the exact center here like this, look
at this, then you can realize that this this
is bottom here and use this price here. They're
not aligned on the exact center. Okay, let
me show you a sample. Okay, if you see this
line here, inside the price quantity selector,
just comment a thing. Okay, save the thing.
Now. There we go. Can you see this thing here?
They are not aligned on the exact center.
Now in order to save in order to solve this
thing. Just come here and then right AIC tap.
Okay, align items center. This thing works
on the x axis and this one works on the Y
axis. Okay, save the thing. There we go. Problem
solved. Okay. Now you're gonna get this code
back like this. Okay, save the thing. There
you go. Perfect. Okay, guys, let's come back
to the file and let's project and then right
click inspect, okay. If you make the things
smaller, let me show you if you make this
thing smaller, how many columns can you see
four, right? If we make a small like this,
there we go. Now it becomes two columns. Okay,
if we make it even further, then it's going
to become one column like this. There we go.
Now this is called a responsive website. Okay.
In order to duplicate the exact same result,
what we're going to do is you're going to
come back to your style css, okay, one second.
Where is the shop? Okay, this shop here below
the shop, we're going to make two media queries.
Okay, look at this, add the RED media. And
then you got right here max minus weight,
okay. So we're going to right here first breakpoint
will be 1000 pixels. Okay. Then you got color
black. Get your gadget dot sharp, curly racket,
okay, inside here, just copy the thing. Okay?
Paste the thing here, okay? Now what do I
want? The moment, the moment the screen hits
1000 pixel, I want the thing to be how many
columns, just two columns, okay? Just specify
to here, done. Save the thing. Okay, now let's
come back here on our result, right click
inspect, Okay, now let's make it smaller like
this. There we go. The moment you what is
the width right now? 1040. Okay, the moment
you hit below 1000 Look at this. Now it becomes
two columns from four columns. Okay, now let's
make it even smaller is not going to work
because we didn't specify the media query.
Let's do that as well. Just copy the entire
thing. Okay? Paste it here and here, specify
500 pixels like this. Okay? And now here,
you're gonna write one. Now guys, save the
thing. Let's look at the result. Okay, make
it below 500 pixels, okay? I mean, through
looking here, okay, something like this. Look,
there we go. It works perfectly fine. Okay.
All right, guys. So far, so good. We have
successfully completed the HTML and the CSS
for now we're going to start the JavaScript
part. Okay. But before that, guys, look at
this one. Can you see these cards here? These
cards have different data, look at the image.
Okay, they are different, though the tax there
are different, the price is different as well.
Okay, so how did I make these cards? I just
did this. Look at this. So how did we do it?
Look at this, inside this div with the class
name shop, we just perfected one card, and
then we copied and then paste the thing. Now,
if you want to replace the data, let's say
that you want to replace the image, then you
have to replace this tag. Let me show you
a sample. Okay. So how do you replace the
thing like this look? So first of all, you
remove the image from here, and then Ctrl
Space, you're going to select Image number
two, then you're going to replace it with
what official office shirt. Save the thing.
Let's look at the result. And wait a second.
Let me just also clear this one and run right
100. Okay, save the thing. Let's look at the
result, guys. There we go. Can you see that?
Now the data changed. Now, how many cards
do you have? You have? How many cards? Let's
see, for cards. Let's say that we have 100
cards? Does that mean that you're going to
manually do all the things? No, guys, obviously
no, don't do it. At the same time, look at
this. Most of the data here, most of the markup
are just copy paste, which means most of the
things are repeating itself again and again
and again and again and again, right? Don't
do this thing, guys. Don't copy and paste
the thing here. In order to solve this issue,
we're going to use JavaScript. Okay, so let's
start the JavaScript. Make sure guys, you
wrote this line at the bottom, okay, otherwise
JavaScript will not work. Okay, the very first
thing that we're gonna do is we're gonna copy
the ID Do you see it here? So my main intention
was I'm not target this inside style css,
and then I'm gonna target this inside ID.
I mean, sorry, inside the JavaScript. Okay.
So let's copy this one. Let's go back to all
main GS. And how do you actually target an
ID inside main js? Look at this. First of
all, you're gonna write a variable, okay?
Let anything you can write anything here.
So I'm gonna write here, let shop like this.
Look, let's shop a call to you just write
your document. Oh, sorry, document. Okay,
then what is this, look at this, it is an
ID, right? So you're gonna write here, dot
get element by ID, then you're gonna write
your bracket, single quote or double quote,
okay, and then you're gonna pay the thing
to get Look at this. There we go. So now we
have successfully targeted our shop. And we
have also saved that inside a variable. Okay?
Now, if you want to test the thing, how the
thing actually works, just save it, okay.
And then at the bottom, we got right here,
console log, okay, console dot log, and then
you just write your shop, like save the thing.
Let's look at the result. Okay, so now this
is the result, you hit F 12, or just right
click, click on the Inspect, okay, now you're
gonna go to this console, here, you see this.
So this entire HTML element came inside the
console. If you open up this one there, we
can see this one here. Now, if you select
on this one, you can see that this thing is
highlighted. If you see that in this one,
the thing gets highlighted. Okay, so we what
did we do, we got the entire markup inside
the console. Okay, we didn't want to do that.
So what my main focus is that I'm going to
make a function here, okay? And then I'm going
to make the function in a way that it prints
me all the cards automatically. Alright, in
order to do that, look at this guy. Look at
this guy. So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to make a function like this, let generate
shop Okay, generate shop. Okay, it's going
to be an ESX error function. So you have right
here equal to sign, this will be your bracket
equal to angle bracket, curly bracket, this
is called es six arrow function. And now guys,
let me show you the regular function. The
regular functions looks like this function,
okay. ABCD bracket curly bracket. This is
called a regular function. This is called
es six arrow function. Okay, we're going to
use this one. Alright guys, now I'm going
to remove the thing. Okay, now, guys, so how
do we stop the repetition? Actually, first
of all follow along with me Do you see these
things? Just how many things are here, four
items are here, right? Let's just remove three
of them like this. Let's just keep one piece,
okay, let's just come back here and use this
function here. Let's trigger the function,
like copy the thing, and then paste it here
like this. Okay, so we're defining the function
here, and then we're invoking it here. Okay,
and there's this console here. We don't need
the console. Okay, save the thing. Now guys
do one thing. Inside here, you're gonna write
a return statement. Okay? Return like this.
Now, guys fought sorry, I made a mistake,
Ray turn. There we go. Now guys, we're going
to use template literal. Look at this guys.
This is called a double quote. This is used
to write strings, we're not going to use this
normal guys, we're going to use backticks.
This is called backticks. So this is used
to make template literals. If you don't find
it, you're going to find this key below the
EXIT key. So look at your keyboard, there's
something called Escape key, I'm an exit key,
okay, below that EXIT key, you're going to
find the backtick. So you just click it one
time, then you're gonna see the backtick.
Okay, so we're not going to use this thing,
we're going to use backticks. Okay, now guys
do this. Inside here. One second, you just
come over to index html, just cut the thing
like this control x, save the thing. Okay.
Now, let's come back here like this. Now,
what you're going to do is, by the way, guys,
one second, just look at the result. We're
going to have nothing, okay. Now, in order
to see some result, do this. Just paste the
thing like this. Okay, save the thing. Okay,
guys, now let's look at the result. Okay,
we're still going to see nothing. Why is that?
That's because you didn't specifically define
that where these things should get printed.
Okay, you didn't define the thing. Now we're
going to define the thing. So in order to
define the thing, like, where do you want
to get where do you want this thing to get
printed, we want this thing to get printed
inside the shop. Because we have defined the
class styles in such style css, look at this,
we already have the grid defined, okay? Which
means that we want the car to get generated
inside here. That's why I selected the shop.
Okay, now, let's follow along with me just
copy the shop like this. Okay, now, come here,
pasting. Then you're going to write dot inner
HTML, and then you're going to hit equal to
site done, save the thing. Okay, now let's
look at the result. There we go. Guys. Can
you see this one card here? We have successfully
generated the card using what? using JavaScript.
Okay, now guys, what we're going to do is
look at this, can you see these values here?
These are called hard coded values, okay?
Which means that we just use your hand to
write the thing. Now we're going to automate
the thing. How do you automate the thing,
look at this, first of all, you're going to
make a array here, look at this, we're going
to let Okay, sharp items, sharp items, equal
sharp items data, okay, equal to you're going
to make a array here like this. Okay. Now,
guys, let's say that we have, how many data
do we have, actually, let's check, we have
1234, we have four data, right? So in order
to write the data inside here, look at this,
we're gonna use curly bracket, this is called
object, which means that we are storing objects
inside the array. If we write one curly bracket,
I mean, if we write one object, which means
that in our shop, we have only one thing to
sell, but if you hit comma curly bracket,
and then if you do it four times like this,
which means that we have how many items to
sell for items to sell, okay? So these are
actually defined inside our objects. Now look
at this list, first of all, make the first
object so how are you going to make the thing?
First of all, you're going to set the ID loop
with this. Id colon, double quote, okay? You
can write it anything you wish, no problem.
I want my just write anything. Okay? Don't
keep it blank. Then you're gonna write a comma.
Okay, then you're going to put a name here.
Oh, by the way, guys, one more thing, this
Id do you see this thing? This should be unique.
Okay. And now on the name, we're gonna write
a casual shirt. Okay, casual shirt. There
we go. Now you're gonna hit comma, you're
gonna set the price. Okay, so what I'm doing
is my main objective is do you see all the
data here like this one? This one, this one?
I'm just storing them here. Okay, so let's
complete the thing. So price is gonna be 45.
Okay, then coma D S, C, description of it.
You're gonna send the description to look
at this double double quotes. Lorem seven,
or eight, tap. There we go. Okay. Now below
this one, you're gonna get image img colon,
double quote, okay, images slash, I m G minus
one dot jpg. Okay, so, to not make any misspelling
mistakes, just scroll down. Do you see this
thing here? Where is it? Ah, this image here,
the sources already here, just copy the thing.
Yeah. And then put it here like this. That's
how you, that's how you don't make any spelling
mistakes. Okay? So look at this, we have successfully
defined one item inside our shop, okay? In
the same way, look at this guys, I'm going
to copy the thing, okay? And then I'm going
to paste it inside here like this, okay, look
at this, which means that we have how many
items? We have four items in our shop at the
same time, those four items has this data.
Okay? Now, guys, as I told you, the ID should
be unique. Let's make it unique. Like, let's
try anything, okay? At the same time, come
here, anything of it? No problem. Come here.
And then I'm gonna give you a random value
like this. There we go. Done. Now, the second
one will be official, let's strike off his
shirt. On the price you're gonna say to 100.
Okay, and the image, just replace the one
with two like this. There we go. Now the next
one will be our T shirt. Set the price to
25. Like this image will be which one, three?
Okay, scroll down, you're gonna set the image
to four, the price will be 300 because it's
a men's suit. Okay, men's. Let's remove this
thing and then right suit. There we go. Done.
Save the thing. Okay. Now, if you go back
to the results screen, you're not gonna, you're
not you're not gonna see any changes. Why
is that? That's because you also have to define
the thing by using a map function. Okay, let
me show you how the map function actually
works. So what you're going to do first of
all is, do you see this backtick here, just
select it up to this backtick here, do you
see this one here? Okay, up to this point.
Now cut the thing. Okay. Now what you're gonna
do is you're gonna right here one second.
Do you see this thing? Shop items data, scroll
down. And you're gonna write shop items data
here, shop there is it okay, sharp items data
like this. Now we're going to use a map function.
Look at this dot map. Okay, here is it. Now
guys look at this. Inside this. We're gonna
right bracket. Okay? Now, put your mouse inside
this bracket, we're going to make an ESX arrow
function. Look at this. Brackets, okay, equal
to angle bracket, and then curly bracket.
There we go. Done. Now, guys, we're going
to pass an argument here, okay, you can write
it anything you wish, no problem. Okay, for
what? For this tutorial, I'm going to make
it very simple. I'm gonna write an x. So why
did they write the x here? The main reason
is that this is math function here, the map
actually will target all the data one by one.
Okay? So which means that how many items are
here? Okay, tell me how many items are inside
here, four items, four objects, which means
that this map will run four times, okay? But
if you have 100 data insert here, which means
that the map will run 100 times. Okay? And
by writing this x, it means that we're targeting
all the items one by one one piece at a time.
Let me show you don't worry. Okay. So inside
here, we're going to write another return
statement. Look at this. Read. Sorry, return
like this. Okay, now whatever you have cut,
you just pay the thing like this. Okay, there
we go. Save the thing. Okay, now let's look
at the result. Guys. Look at this. There we
go. Can you see this one here? But guys, guys,
once again, it looks odd. Okay, look at this
one. Can you see this one? And can you see
this one here? It looks odd. That's because
can you see this invisible coma here? I can
already see it here. Can I see this coma?
Yeah, it's coming. Okay, so we have to remove
this coma only then we can see the specific
result in order to remove the coma. Alright,
guys, come back to your main js and then you're
going to scroll on okay. Do you see this ending
curly bracket before this one? Okay. Do you
see this one here? Just before this one, right,
dot join. Okay, bracket, then double quote.
Okay, done. Save the thing. Yes, look at the
result. There we go, the comma are gone. But
guys look at this, the data did not get changed.
Okay, but we want them to get changed automatically,
how we want to think we want the thing to
get changed automatically. In order to do
that. It's very simple. Guys look at this.
Do you remember the x that I wrote? You see,
it means that we're targeting all of them
one by one, one by one. So how many times
the map will run. First of all, tell me how
many data we have. We have four data. So the
map will run one by one. I mean, sorry, the
map will run four times, and all of them will
run one by one. So now look at this, use this
x here. Let's just come here and use this
casual shirt. You have the casual shirt legs,
okay, now you're gonna hit dollar sign, curly
bracket, then you're going to x dot. Why did
you write the dot because it is actually an
object. So what did you specify here? This
is an object, right? That's what the x is
object. Now look at this. This is name here.
Just copy the name. Okay, scroll down. And
do you see this one here? Just pay the thing
like this. There we go. Done. Save the thing.
Now let's look at the result. Okay? If you
see this name, then you're going to see that
the tags got changed. Look at this this casual
shirt or is off his shirt. This is T shirt.
This is men's suit. Okay, but the image didn't
get changed. Look at this. We're going to
do the same thing. For the price. Look at
it. It's very simple look this, remove the
Fortify but don't remove this dollar sign,
okay? Hit a space now right dollar sign curly
bracket x dot, what was it price, right? p
r i, if you are not sure what to spell. If
you're not sure about the spelling, just come
here. Okay, copy the spelling scroller and
paste the thing here like this, then save
the thing. Okay. Now let's look at the result.
You see, that price also got changed. You
see that? Brilliant. Now guys, look at this.
Can you see this? Every time you have to use
the X, you gotta write x dot x dot x dot.
That's annoying, right? So in order to prevent
that, we're going to use something called
destructuring. Okay, it's very fun to use.
Look at this. So look, look at this. How many
things do we have instant objects? We have
image, we have name, price, description image.
Okay, so now in order to use all of them loaded,
I'm gonna destructure the thing Okay, so come
here, and then you're gonna right here leg,
okay, or not here. Sorry, guys. My bad. It
should be actually inside here. This is map
here. It should be inside the map. Okay, so
you got Russia let curly back equal to x.
Okay, now, do you see these things here, just
copy them one by one. Okay, copy them, put
it here. And then you're gonna hit, comma.
All right, now let's get the name. Paste the
thing here, get the price. And also make sure
to put a comma, pay the thing okay. Then lastly,
we have the description of the image. So Command
D, Sc, comma, IMG, save the thing. There we
go. Now, guys, you don't have to write the
x dot anymore. Okay, so let's, let's remove
the thing like this. Okay, let's remove the
thing from here as well. There we go. Let's
look at the result. So we got the exact same
result, okay, by writing this line of code
and also doing these changes, by the way,
guys, why do we write x dot x dot x dot? Here's
a question. You might have a question, right?
So what is this this object? Right? So in
order to access the object, we write it like
this look. abc.or Sorry. Sorry, what was the
name of the thing? Shop items data, right?
So let's copy the thing. So this so the thing
is object, okay? If you want to, if you want
to access the price, you just write the object
name and then you have to write the dot price
like this. Okay? That's why guys, we had to
write the x dot name because the thing is
object. Okay, because we specify the thing
here as an object. Okay. I really hope that
you understood up to this point and everything.
Okay? Now, guys, I'm gonna remove the thing,
and then I'm going to save it. Okay. Now guys,
do you see this? Where's the image? Here's
the image, right? Copy the thing. Remove it
from here. Okay, source equal to dollar sign
curly bracket, paste the thing done. Save
it. Let's look at the result. There we go.
Can you see that? Now we have different images.
It looks just like our finalized project can
see that. Brilliant guys. Next abducens description
here. Yeah, we're gonna change the description.
In order to do that. We're going to come back
here and we're going to remove this one. Okay,
next up, right dollar sign, curly bracket.
Oh, sorry, curly bracket. And then you got
right head description de SC. Done. Let's
look at the result. There we go, guys. Okay,
we are successful up to this point and everything.
Okay? All right, guys. If you notice carefully,
then you can see that we use the image description
price and the name but we didn't use the ID.
Okay, we're going to use the ID inside the
parent. Okay, so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna write an ID, so we're gonna write here
ID, okay, equal to, we're gonna write here
product. Okay, minus id minus dollar sign
curly bracket, Id save the thing. Now let's
look at the result. Okay? So you're going
to come here, and then you're going to right
click Inspect. Okay, now you're gonna go to
your elements, and then open the shop. Here's
the shop. Okay, now, this is how many cards
do we have 41234. Now you can notice that
all of these cards got itself ID, which is
actually unique. Can you see this one here?
This is a unique ID, unique ID unique ID,
etc. I really hope that you understood up
to this point and everything. Okay? At the
same time, guys, let's come back here. And
you just copy the ID from here, scroll down.
Do you see this quantity here? Yeah, we're
going to put an ID here as well as ID equal
to dollar sign curly bracket paisa thing.
Okay. The main reason for putting this thing
here is that guys, this is zero here. Yeah.
Every time we increment the thing, we're going
to target the ID and then we're going to increment
the number at the same time, every time you
decrement the thing. We're going to target
this one and then we're going to decrement
the thing Don't worry guys, we're going to
make this function right now so that you can
have a practical feel of how the thing actually
works. Okay. All right, guys. So far, so good.
Now we're going to make two functions to increment
and decrement function And my main objective
is that every time you click on the plus the
number will increase. Okay? At the same time,
every time you click on this one, the decrement,
the number will change as well. So we're going
to make two functions, this will be increment,
this will be decrement. Okay, and do you see
this one here, we're going to make another
function which will be called Update, which
will which has only one function to update
the number. Okay? So let's get started. Okay,
let's come back to our alright guys. Let's
go back to our VS code inside the main js.
Okay, do you see this data here is huge, right?
We can fold this how do you fold this? Just
come here click on the shaver. Okay, done.
Now it's more manageable. Okay. Now below
this function, what we're going to write is
two functions. Okay? We're going to make two
functions, increment decrement. Okay, another
function that we're going to make is called
Update, look at this follow along with me,
let is going to be ESX error function, okay?
increment, okay, equal to there's one arrow
function here like this. There we go. Done.
Now, this is responsible for increasing the
number where is it? This one, okay. And we're
gonna make another function which we'll call
diction, okay, copy paste, decree meant, there
we go. Okay. Another one will be called update
something like this look. There we go. Done.
Okay. Now, let me explain. Again, the increment
is responsible for increasing the number decrement
is responsible for decreasing the number and
the update is responsible for updating this
number here. Okay, so far so good, guys. So
guys, I really hope that you understood why
I wrote three functions. Okay, let's go back
to our functions. All right. Now guys, do
you see this icon here? Yeah, and this is
icon here. So you're gonna come here and then
you're gonna right on track, okay. Everything
will be in small letters. Okay, on click on
C L IC K, okay. Equal to double quote. Okay.
Now look at this. These are minus right? Every
time you hit the minus which one should trigger
this decryption should trigger right just
copy the thing hmm. And then come back here
and then pay the thing like okay, now bracket.
There we go. Done. At the same time uses increment
here you go right here on click OK, on click
equal to double quote. Okay, now scroll down.
And due to this increment here, copy the thing,
scroll up and now put it here like this bracket
done. Now, how do you test whether the thing
actually works or not? Let me show you. Just
come over here. And then you go right here,
console dot log. Okay, you're gonna increment.
There we go. And now let's come back here
and then write console log. Okay, no log decrement,
you can decrease that. There we go. Now let's
test the thing. Okay, let's come back to here
on the results screen, and then we're going
to hit right click Inspect. Okay. Now let's
come to your console. And now let's click
on the plus like this. There you can see this
one here is not increment. Okay. Now let's
click on the minus that is decrement. There
we go. Okay, so all the buttons are working.
Let's test all of them. Okay, there we go.
Okay, decrement increment, so it's working
perfectly fine. Okay, guys, here's the question.
How do you exactly know that which card you're
selecting? Okay, I can say that, hey, this
is a formal shirt one, I'm selecting this
one. You can visually see that. But JavaScript
JavaScript doesn't have any eyes. How will
it know that you're selecting exactly this
one? Right, here is the question. So how do
you exactly solve that? It's very simple.
Look at this. Just come over here. And do
you remember this ID here? Yeah, this is a
unique, what is this? This is uni. Using this
ID JavaScript can pinpoint which shop item
you're specifically selecting? Okay? That's
why I wrote here ID and I gave it a unique
ID for all the things so that JavaScript can
identify which item we're selecting. Okay?
Now, in order in order to do the same thing
here, look at this. This is increment and
decrement. We're going to pass an argument
here. How do you pass argument Look at this
guy right here, dollar sign curly bracket,
ID, okay? In the same way, you just come here,
right dollar sign curly bracket, Id done.
Okay? Now listen, guys, scroll down here.
And instead of the increment you right here
ID Okay, save the thing. Let's test. Let's
come back here. F 12. Okay, open the Dev Tools
and click on the plus. Now guys, you're gonna
see a error ID is not defined. That's because
every time you pass arguments inside here,
you also have to define that inside here as
well. Something like this. Look, this is our
argument. Okay? Save the thing. Now let's
do the result. Okay, now, is it gonna work?
There we go. Okay, click on the plus is working
perfectly fine. Now, can you see this one
here? What did it give us? It returned us
the quantity which is actually zero. And now
guys, look at this uses ID here. Yeah, it
is unique. Let's click something else like
this. Do you see this ID is unique. Using
this ID we're going to tell JavaScript that
hey, we are selecting this card here. Just
decrement the number here or increment the
number here, only here don't touch other cards.
words, you got no point. Okay, guys, we want
only the ID nothing else. So in order to do
that, just come back here and now let me let's
write a variable, okay, let selected item,
okay? Selected Item, okay, and then you're
going to pass the ID here like this. There
we go. Now copy the thing, put it here, okay,
save the thing. Let's look at the result.
Okay, so guys, now let's look at the result.
If you click on here, then you're going to
you're not, you're not gonna see any changes.
So in order to see the changes locally, let's
come back here and on a selected item, just
right here.id okay.id Save the thing. Now
if you come back here, if you select on the
plus like this, there we go, you're gonna
see the unique only the unique ID click on
here is the unique ID, okay? Click here, unique
ID click here, unique ID done. In the same
way, guys, let's come back here. Yeah, we're
going to pass the ID here. Okay, we're going
to do the exact same thing just copied both
of these two lines here, and then paste it
here like this. There we go. Done. Save the
thing. Now look at this, every time, whatever
you click, whether it be the plus, or the
minus is going to specifically pinpoint to
the JavaScript that which item you're exactly
selecting. Okay, so far, so good, guys. Now
listen, the next thing that we're going to
build is we're going to make a small basket.
Okay, with this, I'm gonna come here and then
I'm ERATION. Lead, okay, basket. Okay, equal
to is gonna be a array like this. Now, what's
the reason for making the basket? The main
reason for making the basket is that one thing,
let me just fold this code, okay, like this.
The main reason for writing the basket here
is that every time you select any card, okay,
what is going to do is gonna store the data
inside our basket to steal specifically, which
items did we selected? Okay, you got my point.
Now, let me show you an example. Let's say
that we have selected this card, okay. So
if you select on the plus, what will happen
is that look at this. Here, a object will
regenerate it, okay, inside this object, we're
going to have two items stored look at this,
we're going to right here, Id colon, this
will have the unique ID Okay, and then comma,
we're going to have a item here, where the
number will be just one, which means that
we have this item inside of a basket and the
quantity is just one piece. Okay? Every time
you click on the plus something like this
look, every time I click on the plus like
this, so what will happen is reuses 18, number
18. The number 18 will get added here at the
same time. So since you selected this thing,
so this thing will be existing in your basket
by storing the ID here. Let me show you a
live demo. Look at this. First of all, I'm
gonna remove the thing, okay, I'm gonna keep
it blank like this. Look at this guys. Now,
I'm going to scroll down here, inside the
increment. Okay, now guys, now guys inside
the increment, every time when the user clicks
on the increment, Hi, this function will run,
which means that look at this here, I'm going
to right basket, okay, basket, dot push. So
what we'll push inside here, look at this.
Okay, bracket, curly bracket. We're going
to put two things First of all Id Okay, so
do you see this ID here selected item.id.
Copy the thing. Put it here like this. Okay,
now we're going to put here comma. Now the
next thing we're going to put Is it okay,
cool. Now we're going to put here one like
this. There we go. Save the thing. Now listen.
Next thing we're going to do is instead of
console logging the ID, we're going to console
the basket. Look at this BS Katie. Okay, save
the thing, guys. Now cut the thing from here
like this. CTRL X now put it after the push
like this. Okay, save the thing. Let's come
back here. Guys. Open the console. One second.
Let's come here and open the console. Okay,
look at every time you click on the plus,
look at this, you're going to have one item
inside your basket. This is a basket guys.
Look at this. How many items do you have?
You have just one. Okay, now if you open up
this one, you can see that I you can see that
the ID got stored. And then the item is one
piece. Now guys look at this. Every time you
click on the Plus, you can see the basket
getting increased. If you open up this one,
look at this, the same item gets added again
and again. And again. It doesn't make any
sense guys, instead of doing this thing, what
we're going to do is we're going to increase
the item number here. If you click here three
times the it will get changed to three. Okay,
that's our approach, not this approach. Okay,
this doesn't make any sense. It is just wasting
our space here. Okay, in order to make the
thing look at this. Let's just come back to
the main GS Okay, okay guys, inside here,
we're going to make a search function. Okay.
The main objective of the search function
is that is going to search whether the thing
actually exist on the basket or not. Let me
show you. Okay, so look at this one, guys.
How many items can you see here? 123. We have
three identical items. It doesn't make any
sense right? So the search function will search.
Let's say that you select this one, the search
function will search where This thing actually
exists on a basket or not. If it exists, only
the item will increase, okay, the item will
increase like 12345, etc, okay? But if it
doesn't exist, then what will happen is that
this is push here is going to push a new object
inside our basket, and then we can see the
option. Okay? I really hope that you understood
my point of view, okay, let's make the thing,
okay. Now look at this, you're going to come
here and then you're going to make a lead
search, okay? Then you got right here equal
to, you're gonna select the basket like this,
like a basket dot fine. Okay, one second.
So using this find, we're going to search
whether the thing whether the object actually
exists or not. Okay, now, instead, we're gonna
right here, bracket. Instead here, you're
gonna es six arrow function, something like
this. Okay, guys, now, look at this. We're
gonna right here, x, you're gonna do anything
you wish. No problem, guys. So for this tutorial,
I'm just going to pass x as an argument. Okay?
The main reason for pass fail. The main reason
for passing this argument is that is going
to check all the objects one by one. Okay,
that's why I wrote this x. Now, inside here,
what I'm going to do is, I will do is this
ID here, this is unique. Okay, so I will just
search for IDs, something like this. Look,
you're gonna come here, and then you're gonna
write your exit ID. Okay? You're gonna hit
triple equal sign. Next step. Do you see this?
Selected? ID? Yes. Selected. item.id. Copy
the thing. Put it here like this. Okay, so
what do I mean by this? It is just searching
for one thing, one and only thing. It is searching
for the item that you selected. And then we're
just making a quick search. Does the thing
actually exist or not? Next up, guys, look
at this. You're going to make an if else take
a look at this if bracket and then you got
your search. If the search is undefined, look
at this triple equal sign and then you go
right here on define like this. Okay, guys,
what do I mean by this? I mean by this is
that if we don't find the thing that we're
trying to search, only then we're going to
push the object inside the basket. So I'm
going to cut the thing and then put it inside
here. Okay. Else like else, like what do I
mean by else? If we find the thing, okay,
then we're gonna do this look else. curly
bracket, you're gonna write your search. This
is searchable. Copy the surgery patient here
and then you go right here. Plus, sorry, guys,
we also have tried the item dot item, okay?
Plus equals doing right here. One done now.
Now guys, let's look at the result. Let's
come back here. And now look at this. If I
select the plus, look at this, we're gonna
see only one object. Okay, bear with me, guys.
Now, guys, let's look at the logic array.
Look at this. If the thing doesn't exist,
only then pull the thing. If it already exists,
just increase the quantity. Okay, so what
will happen here? In our case, if I select
on the plus like this, that what will happen?
Tell me guys, only the item will increase
because we already have the ID. So which function
is responsible for searching for the thing?
The search is responsible for finding the
thing. Okay, let's come back here. And now
let's click on the plus. Look at that. Let's
open up this one. There we go, guys. We have
the ID and the item increase. Let's increase
it again like this. There we go. Let's open
up this one. There we go. You see item is
now three. Brilliant guys. Now let's click
on this one. Now, guys, one second. How many?
How many object can you see inside this array?
Only one? Now guys tell me, does this thing
exist inside the basket? Yes or no? It's a
no. So you're gonna click on this, you're
gonna click on this now you can see that we
have two objects inside here is the first
one is the second one. And the item is only
one piece. This includes everything like this.
Click on this one. There we go. The item now
increased. So guys, I really, really, really
hope that you understood how the logic actually
works. Okay. In the same way guys, we're going
to make the decrement function. Can you see
this one here, we're going to make the decrement
function. So let's get started. So guys, the
decrement function is more or less quite similar
to the increment function. So follow along
with me guys. Just copy the entire thing like
this. Okay, like this one second. Copy this
and now come over here and delete this thing.
Okay. Make it blank and paste the thing here.
All right. Now guys do use this plus here.
Here, we're gonna put a minus like this look.
Okay, done. Okay, guys, after putting the
minus here, let's look at the result. Okay,
so you're gonna see the result immediately.
Now look at this. I'm going to select here
five time, okay. 12345. Okay, now let's open
up this one. You can see the item five. Now
let's decrement the thing like this look 123
Now the item should be how much two. There
we go. It's working perfectly fine, guys.
Now look at this. I'm gonna select it more
times. Look at this. I'm just gonna click
on the thing. Okay, now look at the result.
If I open it up very last one. Look at this.
Now the item is minus 10. It doesn't make
any sense, right? So what we're going to do
is we have to stop this thing from going below
zero in our good thing. Follow up with me
guys. Just come over here and do is this if
statement here. Yeah, instead of the undefined,
we're gonna write his zero. Okay, now here,
he's gonna be searched dot icon, which means
that one second guys one second. Let me just
undo the things. Okay, one thing where did
they get the search dot item? You might have
a question, right? So we actually got it from
here. Can you see this one here? ID and then
we have something called item. So the moment
the thing hits zero, okay, bear with me, guys.
The moment the thing hits zero, we're going
to stop the process. So that's why I wrote
search dot item equal to zero. Look at this
search dot item. Yeah, insert undefined is
going to be zero, like this. There we go.
And how do you stop the process? Look at this,
do you see these things here, just remove
that curly bracket like this, okay. And now
just right here, return is going to stop the
process completely like this, Your code should
look something like this. Now, guys, let's
test the result. Okay, let's come back here
on the results screen and look at this, I'm
gonna select this 123. Let's look at the result.
There we go. The item is now three. Let's
decrement one, two, let's look at the result.
There we got the item is one, the moment you
click it again, look at this is going to become
zero, right? Which means that if you click
it again, here, look at this. Even if you
click on keep clicking the thing, look at
this, it's not working. Even if I click it
100 times is not working. Why is that? That's
because I completely stopped the process.
Okay, by writing this statement, that return
statement means that just stop the thing.
Don't do anything. Okay? Just like this. So
guys, I really, really, really, really hope
that you understood up to this point and everything,
okay? So you can just pick any card here,
just click on the thing, and then it's incrementing
like this. And if you want to decrement just
click on keep on decrementing the moment it
hits zero, look at this, the moment it hits
zero is not going to do anything anymore.
But if you want to say let's say incriminating.
If you click on the plus now is going to work.
Look at that. Click on the thing. Now there
we go. You see now is one piece. Okay? Now
guys, the next thing that we're going to do
is do you remember the update function where
the update? Here's the update function, we're
going to define the update function right
now. So that it gives us 0123456, etc. Just
like the finalized project, you see this one?
Keep on clicking, you can see the result live.
Okay, so let's do the same thing. In our Google
thing. Let's come back to VS code scroller
uses update, we're going to define the thing.
So guys, first things first, when do you want
the update function to run? We want the thing
to run every time one second. We want the
thing to run every time we click on the plus
or the minus. So let me just show you a sample.
What do I mean by that? Okay, so come here,
and then we're going to take console log console,
dot log, okay, we're gonna write here, the
update function is running. Okay. Now, since
I told you, every time we click on the plus
or the minus, we want the update to run, so
we'll do this. Okay, just copy the update.
Now scroll up to your increment function.
First of all, okay, do you see this one here,
console, log basket before this one, just
pay the thing like this. Okay? Then bracket
done. Now scroll down. This is decrement here,
after the console, log base, a thing bracket
done, save the thing. Now look at the result,
guys. Let's come back here, open the console
again. Now, every time you click on a plus,
the update function is running is working
perfectly fine. Look at this, whatever you
click, however you click the thing works.
Okay. All right, guys, instead of printing
console log, we want to print the numbers
here. Okay? In order to do that, first of
all, let's go back to our VS code, okay. And
now first of all, let's define increment,
okay? Inside the increment. Do you remember
the unique ID, where's the unique ID, here's
the unique ID, okay? Just copy the unique
ID guys. Scroll down, do this update, paste
it here, okay? Selected Item, then just pass
the ID like this loop selected. item.id. Okay,
save the thing. Now, let's come inside here.
And then just write an ID here like this.
Okay, save the thing. Now, instead of just
doing the thing, remove this thing and then
write it. Okay, save the thing. Now, initially,
let's load the result. Okay? So instead of
getting the update function is running, you're
gonna see that unique ID can see that we're
gonna get the unique ID. Okay? Now, guys,
where will this unique? Id lead us to let
me show you the unique ID has attachment here.
If you open a general shop, can you see this
unique ID here? Yeah, it has a direct attachment
here, which means that we can use document
dot get element by ID to replace the number
directly. Look at this. I'm going to fall
listing, scroll down to our update function.
Do you see this one here? First of all guys,
we're going to make a quick search. If and
only if the item exists only then the number
will increase. Okay guys, we're back to VS
code. Now look at this. We're going to make
a search function okay, let search, okay?
Equal to look at this basket, okay dot find,
then you go right here, bracket, insert, here
you go, right? Yes, it's error function, okay,
similar process the way how I is a similar
process, guys the way how I made the search?
I'm going to do it in the exact same process.
Okay, now, do you see the way how I put the
X here? I'm gonna put the X here as well.
Okay, now, what am I searching against? I'm
searching against the Id look at this. I'm
going to write to x.id. Okay, I'm going to
try to match with this ID. If it matches,
okay, then we're going to get some result.
Look at this. Okay, after writing this function,
look at this. Just copy the search. Okay,
and then you put it here like this. There
we go. And this is basket here. Comment the
basket. Okay, I'm in the console, comment
the console. Log here. And comment a console
log here as well. Now Oh, sorry, not this
one. My bad. It should be this one. Okay,
comment that thing? Save it. Let's look at
the result. Okay, guys, let's come back to
the VS code. And now every time you click
on the Plus, you're gonna see a object on
the console. Okay, where is this coming from?
Look at this. It is coming from the update
function, which is the console log is coming
from there. Okay. Now, if you click on incrementing,
incrementing, the thing can you see the item
getting increased again and again and again,
right? So we only want the number. We don't
want the ID. Okay, so how do we only target
the ID in our only target, Id just come here
and then write cert dot item. Done, save it.
Let's look at the result. Every time you click
on the plus to get this, only the number will
increment. Okay? Now, we don't want this thing
to be here. We want the thing to be inside
the zero here. How do you do it? Look at this,
just come back here. And then you simply write
document. Okay? dot get element by ID. And
do you remember this ID? Yeah, copy the thing
and then put it here like this. Okay, then
you gotta hit dot innerHTML equal to search
dot item, which is actually this one. This
is number. I mean, this is console, log, it
is printing number 12345, etc. Just copy the
thing and put it here like this done. Guys.
Look at this. Let's come back here. Every
time you click on the plus, look at this,
can you see the number? It's live? It's working
perfectly fine. Look at this number is working.
How many items are here? Eight. How many items
are here, here and here? 000. This increment
is one. There we go. Right? It's working perfectly
fine. At the same time, guys, let's try to
decrypt the thing. If you click on here, look
at this. It's not working. Okay? The decriminalisation
work, but the increment works. Okay. Why is
that? That's because we need to define the
thing here as well. There's this update, which
is actually on the decrement. It's not defined,
we're going to define it just like the way
we would define it on increment. It's very
simple, guys. Just copy the thing here, and
then put it here and then put a dot here like
this.id. Say the thing. Let's look at the
result. There we go. Okay, let's increment
this 1123456. Let's decrement There we go,
guys. It's working perfectly fine. You see,
there we go. Right. Brilliant. Okay, now,
what the next thing that I want is, guys,
every time you increment a thing, okay, what
will happen is this numbers here, three, eight,
and seven. So what will happen is we're going
to add all the numbers together, and then
we're going to display it on here. So since
currently is what it is zero, so we're gonna
add all the numbers and then we're going to
put it here just like this and look at this.
Okay? So if we add all the numbers is going
to be turned into you see, if you decrement
nothing is working here. incremental thing
like this look, it's working here as well.
Let's make that function guys. So what we're
gonna do is we're gonna come back here and
use these unnecessary comments, you can delete
it, or you can just keep it no problem. Okay?
So at the very bottom, you're going to make
a function, you're gonna name the function
calculation, look at this, let or sorry, let
calculation. This will be ESX error function,
okay, something like this. There we go. So
guys, what are we going to do in this function?
We're going to add all the numbers do you
see this numbers here? We're going to add
all the numbers and we're going to display
it where we're going to display it inside
here. Okay. Okay, guys, here's the question
when and how should the calculation function
run? If you notice carefully guys, so whatever
you do, whether you do the plus or the minus
the update function runs every time right.
So I want the thing I mean, I want the calculation
function to run only when the update function
gets triggered. Okay? So in order to do this
thing, just copy the thing Okay, and then
trigger the thing here like this. There we
go. Done. So listen. So what will happen let
me just show you a sample Okay, so I'm right
here console log. Okay. Console. The log and
the here we are right here, calculation Kel
correlation function is running. Okay, now
save the thing. Now listen, every time the
update function gets triggered, the calculation
function will get triggered as well something
like this look, first of all doing this console
log, remove it or make a comment. Okay, save
the thing. Now guys, let's look at the result.
Okay, let's come back here, open the console,
right click inspect, okay. Now every time
you click on the plus, first of all, let's
go to the console. Okay, every time you click
on the plus or the minus look at this chemistry,
this one here, the number is getting upgraded
one and then we're getting this calculation
function is running. We're getting this comment
from where we're getting it from the calculation
function, which is this one, okay? Which means
that this thing is working perfectly fine.
Okay, now, guys, we need to select this thing.
Do you see the 01? Second? Do you see the
zero here? We need to target the zero. So
how do I target this? Look at this. Okay,
guys, let's go back to our index html here
and then open the nav bar. So do you see this
here? We have a little cart amount, okay,
it is a class, we want it to be an ID so that
we can easily target that inside JavaScript.
Just copy the same thing. Yeah. And then you
put your ID equal to double quote. Okay, now
paste the thing done. Okay, guys, now, copy
the thing again. Let's come back to our main
J S. Okay. Now inside the calculation, look
at this, I'm gonna right here, let lead Cart
icon, Cart icon, equal to we're gonna write
document or sorry, document dot get element
by ID bracket, double quote, faced done. So
what we're doing is we're selecting our icon
here, and then we're storing the selection
inside the variable. So far, so good, guys.
Now, instead of this one, look at this, what
I'm gonna do, I'm gonna right click Cart icon,
dot innerHTML equal to American 100. As an
example, guys, look at this. Okay, so now
if I open up the results can look at this.
How much is this one is just zero. Look at
this evidence, click on the plus is now 100.
But if I click it again, it's not gonna work.
Okay, how do I make it work? So look at this.
I don't want it. This is called hard coded
value. I don't want these guys. No, no, I
don't want this. Look at this. I'm gonna I'm
gonna come here and then I'm gonna hit console.
Okay? Console. dot log. Okay. Now inside here,
I'm right. passkey, B, s, k, et WASC. Save
the thing. Let's go back here and open the
console like this. Okay? Now look at this.
Let's select this one, select this one, okay,
see, like these things and select listen.
Now, if I open up this basket, look at this.
How many things do I have here? I have 1234.
I have four items in my basket. Do you see
the item? Guys? Look at this 2434. What do
I want? I want to add all the numbers. Okay,
so in order to add all the numbers, what I'm
gonna do right now is when I select only the
item, what I'm doing, I'm going to target
only the item, not I don't need the ID, I'm
going to return only the item. How do I do
this, look at this case, just come back here.
And we're going to use a map function look
this basket, right, whereas a dot map, bracket,
you're going to hear ESX error function like
this. Now we're going to pass an argument
x, which means that is going to target all
objects one by one. How many objects do we
have here? 12344 objects, right? The X will
target all of them one by one and is going
to get only the item. Look at this. So in
order to specify only the item, you just hit
Exit item. Okay, item. Done, guys. Save it.
Now let's do the result one second. Click
on here. Okay, click on here like this. Take
this one. Take this. Now guys, can you see
this? We are only getting the number nothing
else. Okay, we are getting only the number.
This is three here. The three is here. This
is the four the four is here. This is five,
the five is here and the three is here. Now
guys, we are going to use a reduced function
to add all the numbers follow along with me
guys. Come back here. And now after this one,
we're going to right here dot radius. Look
at this r e d use E reduce. Okay, now right
bracket. So you're going to write here another
ESX error function like this look, huh? And
now guys, you're going to pass two arguments
here. 1x and another one we call y. So why
did I write x and y? The main reason for writing
x and y is that x and y, one of them is the
previous number. And the other one is the
next number, which means that one second.
So how does the calculation work? Look at
this. First of all, let's consider the three
as x okay? So the three what it will do is
is going to add the three with four. So how
much is three plus four is going to be seven
Okay, so this will be the previous number,
what is the next number of the after seven
is three to seven plus three, how much 10.
Okay, so what is the next number is five.
So, say 10 plus five is how much 15. That's
how this thing will run. Okay, I really hope
you understood how the reduced function should
actually work. Now look at this, we're going
to hit X plus Y. Now, optionally, you're going
to put here comma, and then 00 means it is
a default number, which means that we want
the calculation to start from zero. Okay,
save the thing. Now, guys, let's look at the
result. Now let's come back here and then
write 12345. Can you see this five year? We
have five items. Now let's come here, and
then we add three items. 1233. There you go.
Can you see this eight here? Five plus three,
how much? Eight. The calculation is working
perfectly fine. This add more things. There
we go. Let's decrease something. There we
go is working perfectly fine, guys. But guys,
we don't want the thing to be on the console.
We want it to be here, just like our finalize
project. Okay, in order to put the number
here, very simple, guys. Come back here. There
is this cart icon here. Yeah. Copy the thing.
Come back here. Pay the thing. Okay. Then
you got I had dot innerHTML equal to do use
this console here. Yeah, got the thing. Okay.
Put it here and remove the console from here
like this. There we go. Guys done. Save it.
Let's look at the result. Let's close this
one. Let's increase the thing. Okay, there
we go. You see seven items here, seven items
here. Let's increase it to three like this.
10 items here. Let's try to decriminalising
like the circuits. There we go. You see, it's
working perfectly fine, guys. Okay, so we
are successful up to this point and everything.
But guys, here's the thing. This is number
seven is one and one is nine. The moment you
rephrase the thing, all data are gone. Can
you see that? But if you look at the final
project, look at this. Even if you refresh
the page, it's not going away. Okay, do you
see this one here? I'm refreshing the thing
again, and again. And again, it's not going
away? How is this possible? I am using something
called local storage. If we use local storage,
then we can save this data. Look at this.
If I hit F 12. And if I go to this, here,
there is something called application. Okay.
Now, once again, guys, let me zoom in, there
is this local storage, there's something called
storage, okay, this is a built in storage
of your chrome of your web browser. If you
can order storage on the local storage, you
click on this one. And now look at this. All
the data got stored inside here. Okay? Even
if we refresh, nothing will happen. Look at
this. Can you see this one has zero? ID is
this one, the item is five. So let's find
that one, which is actually this one. Can
you see this one here? The how many? How many
items are here there are five items that if
you make minus look at this, can you see that
the number is changing here, incriminating
look at this, the item is getting updated
at the same time it is getting saved here
as well. However you like you refer to thing,
it's still there, it will never go away because
the thing is getting saved in the local storage.
So guys, we're going to implement the same
functionalities in our project right now.
So let's get started. Okay, guys, after refreshing
it, you can see a fresh instance of this app.
Okay. Every time you click on the plus like
this, okay, look at this. Now, what do I exactly
want to save in the local storage? Look at
this. Okay, we have a lot of data here, right?
I want specifically, I want to put the basket
inside the local storage, okay, so that the
browser remembers which item I picked up just
like this one, you see. So do you see these
things here? Yeah, these things are actually
were inside the basket. Okay. When I use local
storage, the basket got saved inside there.
We're going to use the exact same principle
right now. Okay, so when do you when do we
want to trigger the local search? Listen,
every time you click on the plus or the minus,
we get triggered local storage, something
like this. Look, let's come back here. Yeah,
now scroll down. Give me a second. Where's
the increment? So guys, you're gonna come
here on the increment function, okay, here.
Before the update, you're gonna write a local
search, look at his local storage.if. You
hit dot Nick, I see a lot of functions. Here
you see, get item set item, remove item clear.
Okay, we're gonna use set item, it is used
to set the item inside the local storage,
I am inserting data into the local search.
And the get item is used to get data from
the local search, okay, and the clear is used
to delete everything. delicacy. Now look at
this inside the set item, we're going to have
two things. Look at this. First of all, we're
going to have a double quote. The insert here
you can give any name you wish, no problem,
but let's keep it simple. Okay, I'm going
to name it data. Okay, so this is actually
the name that that gets saved in your local
storage. Let me show you. So if we look at
the finalist project list F 12. And then go
to the application Do you see is key here
the data. That is because I gave it a name
of data. That's the key. If you write, let's
say your own name, let's say that I'm right
here, joy, okay? If I do that, what will happen
is that the key will get named Joy, and then
all the values will get saved here. Okay?
So guys, I really hope that you understood
why I wrote the name here. Okay, this is the
key. So I'm just, I'm just gonna keep it simple.
I'm gonna write your data like this. There
we go. Now you're gonna put a comma here,
and then you're going to pass the basket lines
are gonna be SKD. Basket, save the thing.
Let's look at the result guys, come back here.
And then this is our project. Okay, F 12 to
open the dev tools. And now go to the application.
If you can't find it, just click on here and
then you're going to find some application.
Okay? Now next, we're going to come to the
storage on the local search, open up this
one, okay, like this. There you can you see
this one here, guys, the data is the key,
okay? If you change the name, just do it like
this. Look, you just change the name here,
because that is the key. And this is the object
that is getting stored. Okay? Look at this,
the data is here. I mean, the key is here,
and the value is here. Now, if you click on
this one, then you can see all the details
here. Currently, there are no property. Now
look at it. If you click on the plus, look
at this, guys, what is getting stored something
is getting stored here. We can't read it.
So guys, if we want to read the thing, what's
exactly written here, just like this one,
just like this one. So what you got to do
guys, look at this, follow along with me,
there's something called JSON dot Stringify.
Okay, just got the thing. Got it. You got
it had JSON, dot Stringify. Okay, now bracket
pays a thing like this. There you go. Save
the thing. Now let's look at the result. Let's
come here and refresh the thing. Okay, so
now this, click on here, and then delete the
thing. Okay, now click on the plus like this.
There we go. Okay, we got something here,
just click on this one. There we go. You see
the data got saved here. Now look at this,
we have the 1-234-567-8910. So you have 10
here, the 10 is here as well. Let's try to
decrease the thing. If you decrease the thing
you can see the value is not getting updated.
Why is that? That's because guys, the local
stress exists only on the increment not on
the decrement to do that, just copy the thing.
Yeah, come here and wrote it before the update.
Okay. Put it here like this. There you go.
That same thing. Let's go back and now look
at this. The local storage right now is how
much it's 10 right in Australia decriminalising.
Okay guys, now, let's say is the result. Okay?
First of all, you're gonna need the thing,
okay? Like this. Now let's try to implement
a thing. There we go. You see you got you
got a data, click on this one. And then you're
going to find this. Okay, now let's try to
increment the value Look at this. Click, click,
click, and then you can see that the item
gets incremented. Do you want to recreate
a thing? Sure, why not? Let's do criminal
thing like this. There we go. It is working
perfectly fine. You see, let's add something
like this. Let's add something like this like
this as well. Okay. If you click on here,
then you can see all the details there. Okay,
guys, were successful up to this point and
everything. Now, guys, the moment you one
second, look at this, do you see this three
here, and eight here, the moment you refresh,
everything goes away. But still, Hey, guys,
look at this, the data is still saved here.
So our main task right now is we have to retrieve
the data from the local stores into our application.
Okay, in order to do that is very simple.
Just come over here. So guys in order to retrieve
the data, so what are we doing here, we're
just setting the item inside the local storage.
Now we're going to retrieve the data in order
to retrieve the data just come to the very
top. Okay, do you see this basket here? Yeah,
we're going to remove the thing. Now in order
to get the thing from the local storage, you
have to write JSON dot parse. Okay. JSON dot
parse like this. Now we got actually a bracket.
Now inside the bracket here I can localStorage
Okay, local storage dot get item. Previously
it was set item. Now it is get item now guys,
you're gonna hit a bracket. Now guys, you
tell me what was the name of the key that
you gave the name of the keys data, right?
You're gonna get the data here like this.
Look, you're gonna right here, double quote.
Okay, yeah, hit data. Now the data will get
retrieved. And then guys, we're gonna write
an or statement here, okay. Or, and then we're
going to right here, empty error like this.
So why there right, this was the reason for
this. Okay, look at this guys. So we have
data inside our local storage. What do we
have? We already have the data but what if
we don't have any data? What if we don't have
any data that is going to be error, which
means that is going to break our application
in order to stop preventing from happening
that what we have right is we're gonna give
all statement and then we're gonna give you
an empty array, which was previously inside
here. Do you remember how it was like it was
led? basket equals empty array. Okay? So if
we have local data is going to retrieve that,
if we don't have it, then it's going to be
only an empty array. So I really hope that
you understood up to this point and everything.
Okay? Let's save the thing. Now guys, let's
come back to the results screen and look at
this. It is zero here. And it's for on a Google
search right? In the moment you hit only one
time is going to be five right now. Okay,
this is a five year and this is the five year
now this, if you refresh it, again, it's gonna
start from zero. If you click here, one time
is going to be six. This is the behavior that
we don't want. Okay, in order to prevent that.
And in order to update all the things altogether,
what you're going to do is you're going to
go to your template, do you remember the template?
Where is the template? Here's the template.
Okay, just open up this one. Now, look at
this guys below this one, we're going to make
a quick search. Okay, we're going to say let,
okay, search. Okay, let me actually explain
why did write this search and why I'm making
a search function here. Okay, so after saving
the thing, let's go look at the results screen.
Okay, look at this. So what do I want? Look
at this, how many objects are actually inside
here? Two objects, okay? The first one is
six. And the second one is actually three,
and the other ones are actually zero. Okay,
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna search
specifically for the ID and the item, if the
Id already exists on the local stores, just
get the six and put the six here. If it doesn't
exist, then do nothing. Okay, that's why I
wrote a search function here. Okay. Now let's
define the thing. Okay, so you're gonna write
an equal to, then you're gonna write a basket,
okay? Basket, dot find, bracket, and then
you're going to hear an arrow function, you're
going to pass here, x, okay? Look at this.
x.id. So what we're matching against, we're
matching against the ID. So you're gonna write
triple equal to sign. And then do you remember
this ID here? Yeah, just pass the ID here.
So it's gonna check for all the ID one by
one. Okay, guys, now we're gonna write an
or statement here, look at this, or an empty
array. So what do I mean by that? I mean by
that is that if we can find something, then
store it here. Okay? If we don't find anything,
just return an empty array. Okay, so far,
so good, guys. Alright, guys, copy this search,
scroll down. And this is zero here, remove
the zero. And then you're going to write here,
our dollar sign curly bracket. Okay, put the
search here. Okay, so what do I want to search
tells me, I want to search for the item only.
I don't want the ID. So what I'm going to
do look at this. Let me just go back there.
And now I'm going to right here search dot
item, okay? Like this, okay, if the search
that item is equal to undefined, which means
that if we don't find it, then we're going
to only return zero. But if we find it, then
we're going to return search dot item, something
like this, there we go. Done. Save the thickness
to get the result. Again, so this is the result.
Look at this, automatically, we got the 603.
Even if we refresh the thing, look at this,
it still works. Can you see that six is here,
three is here, let's put here 512345, something
like this, refresh the thing. There we go.
This five is still already there. But nothing
is and now nothing is getting deleted. This
is the result that we exactly one. And now
guys look at this. Even if we refresh the
page, nothing goes away. You just increment
a thing like this. And then you declare the
thing like this, there we go is nothing is
going away. The only problem is with this
one, look at this. How much is this? 12, right,
refresh the thing like this, it's it goes
over to zero. But if you increase the thing,
look at this three, right? Is it like this,
there is going to be 13? You see, there's
the only issue that we have to fix. Very simple,
guys, the solution is very simple to come
back to your main just scroll down. And then
do you see this one here, just copy this one
and then invoke it one time like this done.
So what do I mean by this, I mean by this
is that every time the application loads,
this will run, which means that it's going
to do a quick calculation, and then it's gonna
print the data here. So look at this, even
if I refresh the page, look at it's just the
13 still stays there. Let's try to increment
the number Look at this 17 They started decrement
the thing like this, or perhaps this increment
even further is 24 right now refresh the page.
There we go done. So far. So good guys, we
have successfully implemented the local storage
feature into our application. Alright guys,
before moving forward, we have some problem
in our code, which we need to fix. For an
example look at this. If I put my mouse over
here, the cursor doesn't change the pointer
compared to the Finalize project. Look at
this. If I put my mouse here, the cursor change
changes to pointer, okay. In order to solve
that issue, just come back to your style css
at the very top, okay, below the body, you're
going to hear it. Okay. So what I'm doing
is I'm targeting all icon, HTML elements,
okay, and then I'm setting setting the property
to curb boy or girl boy, tab, cursor pointer,
save the thing. Now let's look at the result.
Okay. So every time you put your mouse here,
the cursor changes to pointer. Brilliant.
Okay, guys, the next problem is actually with
the minus button. Okay? So the problem is,
the minus button shows an error on the console.
Every time the local storage is blank. Let
me show you what I mean by that. Okay, so
guys, you're gonna right click, you're gonna
hit Inspect, okay, come over to your local
application, local storage like this. Now,
do this guys, click on here, delete the entire
thing. So now refresh the page, go back to
the console. And now click on a minus, can
you see that guys? We're having an error.
So guys, why is this happening? Let me show
you. So you're gonna go to your main js on
the decryption function, okay? The error is
actually coming from here. Why is the error
coming? Let me tell you, since guys, the local
storage is blank, which means that the basket
is also blank. If the basket is blank, you
cannot find anything, which means that eventually
the search will be undefined. And in order
to handle the undefined, we don't have any
FL statement. Right? So that's where the error
is coming. In order to stop the error, you're
gonna write another if statement here, okay,
then you're gonna hit Search equal to undefined.
Okay, then you're gonna just return the thing.
So what do I mean by this line, I mean by
this line is that every time when the search
is undefined, then do nothing. Okay, now this
line will stop the process. And guys, do you
see the second line? You just write here else?
If Okay, something like this, else, if, and
then save the thing done. Now let's look at
the error. Okay? So first of all, make sure
that your local storage is blank. Okay. Now
let's go back to the console. Now click on
the minus. There we go, guys. There is no
error right now. Brilliant. Now, guys, let's
move on to the third problem. So in order
to demonstrate the third problem, first of
all, add something on your cart. Okay? Add
something like this. Okay, there we go. Now
guys do this, go to your inspect and then
go back to your local storage like this. Okay,
now, what is this actually telling me? What
is this? This is our basket. Okay, so it's
going to show us which products we selected
along with the specific quantity that we selected,
okay? This is what this is a quantity. Okay.
So as an example, let's say that I don't want
anything from here, I don't want the shirt,
zero quantity, let's make it zero like this.
So I made it zero, which means that I removed
the thing from my basket. Even though you
can see a zero, you can see some data here
that is getting stored. Okay, so guys, there
is no point in keeping something on the basket,
which has a quantity of zero, it doesn't make
any sense. So we need to remove this line.
Okay, which line we have to remove this zero.
So guys, in order to do that, just come back
to your VS code on the decrement function.
Okay, guys, come back to the main Jas on the
decrement function. Okay, follow along with
me guys. Look at this what I'm doing, I'm
gonna write here a basket. Okay, equal to
I'm gonna write the basket again. And then
I'm going to use the filter function. Look
at this. I'm going right here dot filter,
okay, something like this. Now you're gonna
see a bracket. Inside here, you're gonna write
an ESX error function like this, okay? And
inside the argument, you can pass anything
you wish, no problem. But for this tutorial,
let's make it simple. I'm gonna pass it x.
Okay. Now, what are we filtering against?
Look at this, we are filtering against the
item, right? So now we're gonna select the
extra item like this. Don't worry, guys, let
me I'm going to explain this. First of all,
let's write the entire statement. Okay. So
x dot item, okay, not equal to zero. Okay,
guys, now let me explain the meaning of the
statement. Do you see this basket here? What
is this? And what does it actually carry?
Let's keep it side by side with our local
stores and VS code, okay, the basket on the
local shirt is actually array. Okay, inside
this area, it carries all the products that
we selected from the store. Right? And next
up, we have applied a filter function here.
So what do I mean by this x of the filter
function? Do you see this here, we have how
many objects here we have four objects 1234.
So throw the X of the filter function, I mean
that target all of these objects one by one,
one by one. Okay. Next up, what we're checking
is against the item. So look at this individual
object here. How many things can you see here?
We have two things, ID and the item. We don't
need the ID, we only need to check the item.
Okay. So that's why I have written this extra
item. And what do I mean this entire line
extra item is not equal to zero, throw this
I mean that we're going to select all the
objects with which doesn't have a zero on
the item. So guys, you tell me how many objects
do we have on which the item is zero? Only
one object which has an item of zero, which
means that this filter will remove this object,
and then it's going to return the other things.
So guys Once the filter function returns the
filtered data, what we're doing next is that
we're saying we're sending the data back to
the basket. So guys, do you see this line
here? We're going to cut the thing, and then
we're going to put it at the bottom like this.
Okay, so why did they do such a thing? That's
because do you know the mechanics of JavaScript?
JavaScript runs from the top to the bottom
like this? Okay. Now, guys, let's analyze
our code. What are we doing in this lines?
Using these lines? We're manipulating I mean,
we're editing data of our basket, which carries
all the products that we selected. And what
are we doing with the local storage set item.
In this line, what we're doing is we're saving
those data of the basket inside the local
storage. So the main reason for putting these
things at the top, and this is one of the
bottom is that we want JavaScript to run this
lines of code, first of all, so that we can
have the necessary edits and changes on the
data of our basket. So once that's done, what
we want JavaScript to do next is that we want
it to save all the data, I mean, save all
the Edit updated data back to the local storage
like this. So if I cut the thing from here,
and then if I put it at the top like this,
then this then guys, it doesn't make any sense.
What does it mean? So JavaScript, what it
will do is whatever basket data you have,
JavaScript will just save the thing, first
of all, and then is going to do all edits,
which means that guys, you cannot see the
updates on the local storage. That's why guys,
you have put the local storage at the bottom
like this. Okay, so guys, I really hope that
you understood why I wrote this at the bottom.
In the same way, you're gonna open the increment
function here. And then this local search
here, you just got the thing from here like
this, and then put it at the bottom like this.
Okay, save the thing. There we go. Done. Now,
guys, let's inspect our code. Okay, let's
just fold it first of all, now, guys, save
the thing. Inspect the code. Okay. So now
we have a zero here, right? Let's refresh
the thing. Let's see whether it works or not.
So first of all, let's delete the data. Okay,
refer the thing again. And then I select something
here like this. Okay? Select something here.
There we go. This select on this one, you
can see the data here. Alright guys, now let's
test the result do is this four here is actually
here, okay? Every time you click on the plus,
it works, okay? If you click on the minus
minus also works. So let's go and make it
zero like this. Okay? 321, it should be zero,
right? It doesn't work, but instead is giving
us an error. Why does it actually happen?
That's because of the serial Look at these
guys. Do you see this one here? That's because
the serial, so we want the update to run first,
and then we want this line to run. Okay, so
since it is in the opposite direction, that's
why we can't see the changes. So in order
to fix that, guys, just cut the thing from
here. CTRL X, put it here like this. Okay,
there we go. Now guys, save the thing. And
then let's look at the result. Okay. Now let's
come here, and then refresh the thing. Now,
how many things can you see here? Just one
piece. Okay, click on here. Done. Now it's
zero at the same time, it removed the object
from our basket. Brilliant. Let's test it
here. Is 3210. Gone? Can you see that? Let's
test this one as well. 43210. There we go.
Guys, we are successful up to this point.
All right, guys. So far, so good. Now we're
going to make the cart page. Okay, so let's
look at the final test project, the cart page
should look something like this, can you see
this. So let me give you a small demo, this
will be the total bill okay, then we're going
to have two options, either the checkout option
or the clear cart. So what this will do is
going to delete everything from here. Next
up this little card here. This represents
all the items that we selected from the shop
page. All right, and now look at this one,
this is the unit price, okay, the price of
one single piece, this is the quantity and
this is the total price. And this total price
is actually calculated by multiplying this
45 by two. So if you click on the Plus, you
can see that the price increased here at the
same time, the total bill increases here like
this. Let's just again like this, look at
that. Okay, you can also decrementing like
this, there we go. Let's say that you don't
want the thing. So you can just click on the
crosshair like this, and it's going to entirely
remove the thing like this. There we go. Okay,
something like this. Look at that. Now, let's
say that you don't want anything you don't
want to buy anything, you just click on the
clear cart is going to remove everything and
that is going to show you an option called
cart is empty cart is empty, you can go back
to the home, something like this. There we
go. You see. Now let's start building the
cart page. Alright guys, in order to make
the cart page, let's go back to our VS code,
okay, and on the folder structure, let me
zoom in a little bit so that you can see it
better. Here. We're going to create a new
file. We're gonna name it car dot HTML, okay,
car dot HTML, something like this. Okay, now
Now guys follow along with me, we're going
to create a folder we're going to image source.
So the main objective of creating this folder
is that we are going to store all of our stylesheet
and JavaScript file inside here so that we
can manage our folder structure in a neat
and clean way. Okay, so guys follow along
with me. Okay, just drag the main Yes, here
and the style css here like this. Okay. So
since guys, we change the folder structure
here, we have to go back to the index html,
okay. And do you see this links here, this
one and this one here, we have to, we have
to update this. Otherwise, we can see something
like this. Can you see this one here. So in
our project, no JavaScript and no stylesheet
got applied because we update the folder structure
here. So we have to make those updates here
as well. So come here, and then write source
slash save the thing. Scroll down to the script
here. You're gonna write your source slash
major, save the thing. Now let's look at the
result. If everything goes, well, you should
see something like this, you see. Alright,
guys, perfect. Let's go back to our folder
structure here. Do you see this index html?
For this page, we have this main js file.
And for the cart HTML, we're going to have
another file, we're gonna name it, cart, dot
chair, something like this. Okay. Now, guys,
let's go back to our cart HTML here, we're
going to add some boilerplate code, okay,
something like this. exclamatory sign, tap
Done. Now, guys, we don't have to write anything
from scratch, we just copy paste lines from
the index html. Okay. So come back to the
index html, scroll up. Do you see these three
lines here? This is the bootstrap icon. This
is the link for the style css, and this is
the title tag, okay, just copy the three lines,
something like this. Okay. Copy the thing.
Let's go back to our cart HTML and then replace
the thing with this. Okay, there we go. Done.
Now, guys, here, you're gonna write the script
source control space, you're gonna go to your
source, and then you're going to select the
current Jas. Okay, save the thing, guys. Okay,
guys, this is the finished project. Can you
see this nav bar here, this is the current
page, if you go back to the home page, you
can see the same nav bar here, which means
that we don't have to build anything from
scratch, we can just copy paste the thing
inside our cart page. But guys look at this.
Can you see this on here, if I click on here,
it goes to the cart page. If I click on here,
it goes back to the home page. This is the
navigation and in order to build that we're
going to use the anchor tags. So let's implement
those things in our project. So guys, you're
gonna go to your index, HTML first. Okay.
Now in order to do the navigation part, you're
going to hit here a tab, okay, control space,
it should lead us back to the home page. Okay,
got this h2 tag from here. And then we're
going to paste it here like this. All right,
now let's make another anchor tag, which will
lead us to the cart page. Okay, something
like this. There we go. Now, inside here,
what we're gonna do is use this div here,
just copy the entire thing. I mean, cut the
entire thing, then paste it here, save the
thing, guys. Now do this. You just close the
nav bar here like this, copy the entirety,
go back to the cart HTML. Now inside the body
tag, paste the entire paste the entire thing,
okay? Then you can also fold it like this.
Save the thing. Okay, now guys, let's look
at the result. Okay? If everything goes, well,
it should look something like this. Can you
see this on here? It looks odd. It was previously
why in color, but why is that? That's because
the anchor tag actually have some default
styles which we which we need to remove. So
come back to our style css at the very top
here. Okay, below the ID tag, we're gonna
write a curly bracket, okay, TD tap, text
decoration, none. And then we're going to
set the color to white. Okay, something like
this. There we go, guys. Now let's look at
the result. So it should look something like
this. Okay, now guys, look at this, we can
navigate between the cart page like this.
We can also go back to the home page. There
we go. Right. So far, so good. But guys, there's
a little bit of problem. Can you see this
number here is 15, one, five. But if you go
to the cart page like this is zero. Why is
this actually happening? Let me tell you.
The main reason is that this card J space
is totally blank. It doesn't have any data.
That's why we're seeing a zero here. So guys,
in order to fix that thing, what we're gonna
do is we're gonna look at this guy's Do you
remember our local storage here, let me show
you. We have all the data saved here. What
we're gonna do is we're going to pull this
data inside our cart. Yes. Okay, so guys,
we don't have to write anything from scratch.
Let's just go back to the main Jas. Okay.
Now, do you see this line here? Let Baskin
equal to this one. So is already doing a job
of pulling data from the local storage. So
what is this? This is trying to pull data
from the local storage. If we don't have anything,
only then it's gonna return us an empty array.
Okay, so guys, let's just copy the thing.
And now let's go back to the cart page, paste
the thing done. Now, in order to be sure whether
the thing whether the thing actually works
or not just console log Okay, okay, console
dot log. Okay, we got it a basket, something
like this, save the thing, guys. Now let's
look at the result. Okay? So if you go to
the console here, you should see data coming
back from the local storage, something like
this. But guys, the 15, the number 15 is not
here. If we go back to the home page, the
15th is here, but actually not here. So in
order to solve that issue, guys, do you remember
that we created a function inside main js
is named was calculation. Do you remember
this? So what is the job of this calculation?
Tell me guys, the main job of the calculation
function is that let's go back to our data
card page. Okay, so now let's open up this
data. The main job of the calculation function
is that this is items here, it got some number,
okay, so what the calculation function will
do is that is going to add all the numbers,
okay, and then he's going to show it here.
So guys, in order to solve this issue, let's
go back to our main Jas. Okay, here, let's
copy the entire calculation function along
with this statement. Okay, just copy the thing.
Let's go back to our car js and then paste
the thing here. Now, guys, we don't need this
one anymore. Let's remove the thing. Save
the thing, guys. Now, guys, let's look at
the result. If everything goes well, then
you can see 15 Here, if you go back, you have
the 15 here, okay, let's select something
else. Let's say that we're going to select
these things up to let's say 15. Okay, now
you can see that previously, it was 50. Now
it's 30. It's 30. Right now, if you click
on here, then you can see that that thing
also got updated along with the homepage.
Next up, guys go back to the VS code on the
main Gs, and then you're going to scroll to
the very top, do you see this variable here,
this variable name is shop items data, what
is this actually, this is an array which carries
all the data of the products that are listed
on the shop page, we can also create a separate
file for this gigantic data. In order to do
that, what you're gonna do is you're gonna
foster folder thing, okay, then cut the thing
from here, okay, now on the folder structure,
look at this inside the source, click here,
then you're going to create a new file, you're
gonna name it data, dot chair, something like
this, then you're gonna hit enter the variable
that you have got, you're going to paste it
here like this. Okay, let me zoom out a little
bit. I'm going to scroll up using this one
here, it got here, save the thing, guys. Now
if you look at the results screen, you can
see that the entire thing broke down something
like this, you see, shop items, data is not
defined. So in order to include this data
JS back into the main js, do you know what
you're gonna do? You're gonna go to your index
html, and use this line here. Before this
one, you're going to include it like this
look, script source, okay, one second script
source control space, you're gonna go to your
source, then you're gonna select Gita GS,
okay, save the thing. Now, let's do the result,
guys. Now guys, look at that we have no errors.
So guys, I really hope that you understood
how I broke down a big file into two different
smaller files. Okay? In the same way, what
we're gonna do is you're going to go to your
cart HTML, okay? And before this line, you're
going to include the same script, something
like this look, script source, control space,
go to your source, then your ASP. Net data,
Jas, say the thing, okay. All right, guys.
Now we're going to start writing the HTML
markup inside our body tag. Okay. So below
this nav bar, we're going to create a div
with the ID label something like this look,
hashtag label, okay, at the same time is going
to have a class name of text center dot text,
minus center, tap, there we go. Our main objective
is to target this inside JavaScript and target
this one inside style css. Okay. Below this
line, we're going to create another div with
a class name shopping cart. Look at this dots
shopping. Minus cart. Okay, at the same time,
we're going to give it an ID of the identical
name something like this look, hashtag shopping.
Okay, minus cart. Tab. There we go. We can
target this in JavaScript. This will be targeted
inside style css. Now guys, you might ask
me a question like, what's the main reason
for creating this one? And the main reasons
for creating this one? Let me show you guys.
If we go back to the file, let's project here.
Okay, let's go to the cart page. Now, do you
see this component here, the total bill and
the checkout clear card, this component will
be actually built inside here. And do you
see this on here, inside here, what we're
going to do is we're going to build this cards
here. So guys, I really hope that you understood
why I created these two thieves, okay. We're
not going to write anything inside this two
days. We're going to create these two components
using JavaScript. So first of all, do this
guys first of all do is Id here we're gonna
select both of them inside the JavaScript,
okay? First of all, target the label. Okay,
let's go back to our card, GS. And at the
top, what you're gonna do is you're gonna
right here, let label Okay, since this this
is an ID, you're gonna write your document.
Okay, document. dot get element by ID. You're
gonna write brackets, single quote, double
quote. Face the thing Okay, done. Next step.
You got it. Let shopping cart okay shopping
cart equal to document dot get element by
ID okay brackets single quote double quote
like this. Let's go back to our cart HTML,
then you're going to copy this and use this
ID here. Yeah, copy the thing. Let's go back
here and paste the thing like this. There
we go. Done. Okay, guys, so far, so good.
Now guys, do you see this one here, on the
far less project, we have all the cards here.
Okay, we're going to target, we're going to
build this one, first of all, and then we're
going to build this one later on. Okay. So
in order to build all of these cars, we're
going to create a function, the function name
will be generate cart items follow along with
me guys. Below the calculation we get right
here, lead, generate, generate card items,
okay? This is gonna be an ES six arrow function,
something like this. Okay, then we're gonna
write curly bracket. Okay, guys, listen to
me carefully inside this function, we're going
to have two cases. The first case is when
we will have data on the basket. And the second
case is when we will have no data on the basket.
Let me show you what do I mean by that? First
of all, save the thing. Okay, let's go back
to the finalized product. Okay, to look at
these guys, this is the first case when we
have some data on the local storage. Let's
say that we don't have any data. So if we
have data on the local storage, then the thing
will look something like this. But if we don't
have any data on the local storage, then what
will it then what will it look like? It will
look something like this look, if I clear
the card, there is going to look like this.
Okay, cart is empty back to hope. So in order
to generate both of these two components together,
we're going to use the if else statement.
Okay, in order to do that, let's come back
to the card Jas, and inside here we're gonna
write an if else statement. Look at this guys
follow along with me. So guys, we're gonna
write an if else statement here, okay, if
bracket curly bracket, okay, on the next line,
we're gonna write else curly bracket, okay?
So inside this bracket, you're gonna write
basket dot length, okay? is not equal to zero.
Okay, so what do I mean by this if else statement,
by this, I mean that when the basket length
is not equal to zero, you're gonna write,
you're gonna run this code, or else you're
gonna run this code, okay? So let's test the
result. Okay, so we're gonna write a console
over a console, dot log. Okay, we got it,
a basket is not empty. Okay? And now inside
this L statement, we're going to add console,
log console. The log, we're going to right
here basket is totally empty. Okay. Now after
saving the result, just copy this thing. And
then we're going to invoke the function here.
Okay, now, bracket, save the thing. Let's
look at the result. Okay. So this is a result
screen here, you are going to go to a cart
HTML page, okay, like this. Can you see this
one? Here? It is written basket is not empty.
But guys, let's go to the application. Local
Storage. Okay, let's clear the entire thing.
Now let's refresh the thing. Go back to the
console. Okay, you can see that basket is
totally empty. So guys, I really hope that
you understood how this if else statement
is working. Okay. So guys, let's remove the
console from here like this. Okay. And before
writing the if statement, let's finish the
else statement. First of all, okay, so what
you're gonna do is you're gonna scroll up
this this shopping cart here. Yeah. What is
it doing? It is targeting the ID from the
HTML element. Okay, so copy the thing, and
then scroll down the page, the thing here
and then you got right here, dot innerHTML
equal to backticks. Okay, we're going to make
it just blank like this. And on the next line,
what you're going to do is do room with this
label here, which is also coming from the
HTML element. Okay, just copy the thing, scroll
down here, okay, paste the thing like this,
then you're gonna write hate dot innerHTML.
equal to, what we're going to write here is
look at this, first of all, we are back to
you, okay? Then you're going to hit h2, tab.
And guys, here we go. Right card is empty.
Okay, something like this. Empty. And on the
next one, you're gonna write here, a tab.
Okay, so what this will lead us to this anchor
tag, which will lead us to index html, which
is the home page, okay? Index dot HTML. Okay,
so inside here, what we're going to write
is we're going to create a button, look at
this, bu TT o n dot, we're going to attach
a home button class name or something like
this, then you're going to hit tab. There
we go. Now, can you see this one here is student
class name. Don't do it, guys. Otherwise,
it's not going to work. So it should only
be a class not class name. Now insert here,
we're going to go back to home, something
like this. So bad to have done, save the thing.
Now let's look at the result guys. Now guys,
if we look at the results screen, it looks
something like this. The cart is empty. And
back to home page. We're seeing this component
here. Now what we're gonna do is we're going
to put it on the exact center in order to
do that, come back to your style css here,
okay, and at the very bottom, come to at the
very bottom here like this. And we're gonna
write first of all a comment. Okay, so we're
gonna write a comment like this. Okay, start
exclamatory sign here we're gonna write style
rules for style rules for label and add some
buttons. Okay? Something like this. Save the
thing. Now below this one, we're gonna write
text center. Do you remember this guys one
second. On the cart HTML, do you see that
we have a class of text center, just copy
this from here. Okay, come back here and paste
it like this, okay, dot paste, curly bracket.
Inside here, you're gonna write T, a tab,
then center. Okay, then you're going to add
margin bottom, 20, pixel, okay, MB, tab, 20.
Pixel, save the thing. Now let's do the result,
guys. The result looks should look something
like this. And guys, the main reason for putting
the margin bottom 20 pixel is that if you
look at the Finalize project here, then you
can see this gap here, this gap is actually
margin bottom of 20. Pixel. You can't see
it here. That's because we don't have those
cards getting generated here. Okay, this is
back to Home button. We're going to style
it right now. So let's go back to our style
css here. We're gonna right home button one
second, guys. Let's first of all, come back
to the card. HTML. Okay. Not here. Sorry,
guys card GS. And this is class name here,
home button, copy the thing. Come back to
your style css and then you're gonna hit dot
paste. Okay, there you go. Right here curly
bracket. So you're gonna set the background
color BGC tap, remove this thing, and then
you're gonna hit control space. Do you see
this color here? 212529. Get this one. Okay,
next time, you can either color to be white.
Okay. Next up, we are going to remove the
border, okay, border none. Okay, then we're
going to apply some padding of six pixels
to all sides. Okay. Next, we're going to add
the border radius to three pixels, a border
radius, three pixel. Okay, guys, next up,
we also need a little bit of cursor pointer.
Okay, girl, boy, tap, save the thing leads
to good result. Okay, it looks something like
this. But guys can see this card is empty
and the back to Home button. There is no gap
in between. Let's apply some gap. In order
to apply those gap. Just come here and then
right empty. 10 pixel, tap. There we go margin
top 10 pixels save the thing. Let's look at
the result. Can you see this on here? We have
a little we have a little bit of cap here.
So far. So good, guys. Now let's test the
thing. If you click on back to home, it should
lead you back to the home page. Can you see
that guys? Perfect. Let's go back here like
this. There we go. So guys, it's working perfectly
fine. But here's the question actually, why
are we seeing this component? The main reason
for seeing this component is let me show you
guys. So do you remember this function here
on the card GS, we have it Okay, generate
cart items, we have an if else statement here.
So the if statement will run only when the
local stress is not empty. And the else will
run when the local storage is empty. Look
at these guys. We don't have anything on the
basket is totally zero, right? Let's go back
to the homepage here. Let's select something
okay, I have selected this thing here. So
now the local storage is not empty, our basket
is not empty. If you go to the cart page.
Now look at this. This component is not rendering
again. Why is that guys there is because now
the LC is not running the if statement is
actually running, but it is not defined is
totally blank. That's why we can't see anything
here. Let's go back to the homepage here.
Look at this. Now let's remove the thing like
this. Okay, let's make it zero. Let's come
back here. Look at this, we can again see
the component that's because this time the
else is running. So now guys, let's actually
define the if statement here. Okay. So guys
follow along with me. So on the if statement,
we can write in return here. So what is it
going to return? Look at this. We're going
to scroll to the very top there is this shopping
cart here. Yeah, copy the thing, scroll down
here, and then we're going to pay the thing
like this. Okay, now we're going to hit dot
innerHTML equal to we're going to target the
basket. Do you remember the basket? Where
is the basket? The basket is actually here.
And what is this? This is an array which carries
all of our selected products. Okay, inside
the basket, we're going to make a map like
this. Okay? Then bracket, we're going to write
an ESX arrow function like this. Next step,
you're going to x here. The main reason for
running the exe is that let me show you one
second guys. Let's go back to the home page
here. Let's select something. Okay. Let's
select something like this. Let's go to our
local storage here like this. Where is it?
Let's come here. Here. Application local storage.
Okay, guys, this is the local storage data.
The main reason for writing this exe is that
is going to target all of these objects one
by one, one by one. Okay, guys, that's why
I wrote this x here. Okay, you can read anything
you wish. No problem. Okay, I'm just gonna
keep here x. Now next up here, I'm gonna write
a curly bracket. Okay, enter. Next step, guys.
Let's return something again. Okay, we're
going to return here, a template literal.
So we're going to actually have backed Okay,
now inside here we're going to create a div
with a class named cart item. Look at this
dot cart minus item. Okay. Yep. And this is
class name here, which should be only class.
Otherwise it's not going to work. Okay? Save
the thing. Let's write something here. Okay,
hello, like this. Save the thing. Let's look
at the result. There we go. If we go back
to the cart page, you can see some Hello here,
one second guys can says hello, hello, hello.
Why is it repeating four times? Okay, you
might have a question like, why is it repeating?
If you recall, what did I tell you? The X
where's the X guys, this x will target all
the data from the local search one by one
one by one and then is going to run this function
here can see this one here is going to target
all of them one by one, and then it's going
to tag and then it's going to run this function.
That's why we got the Hello four times. But
let's say that one second guys, how many data
do we have here? 41234. Let's say that I'm
going to make something zero. Okay, I didn't
want anything here. If we go to the cart page,
right now you can see three Hello. Why is
that? That's because we only have three items
selected inside our basket. Now there is something
strange here this little icon suggested resuming.
Do you see this uncommon, comma here, we don't
need the comma. In order to remove that comma,
just come back here and do is this here. Just
come you just come here and then you can write
dot join. Okay, brackets, single quotes or
double quote like this, save the thing. Now
guys, let's look at the result. Okay, you
can see that the strange comma is God. Brilliant.
Let me just scroll out from here like this.
And this is the thing that we don't want guys.
We want it to look something like this. Okay,
in order to make the thing we have to write
nice code here. Okay, so let's get started.
Let's run the hello from here. And then we're
gonna hit enter. Okay, inside here, we're
going to first of all include the image. Do
you remember the image guys? So I'm gonna
actually img tab. Okay, the source will be
the source of the image will actually come
from the data. Jas, can you see this one here?
Data Jas. Yeah, we have all the data here.
Okay. So look at these guys. Did we include
this on the cart? HTML or not? Yes and no,
let's just check the thing. Okay, let's go
to our cart HTML and look at this. Okay, so
before the cart GS, we have the data Jas which
means that we can freely use this one this
variable inside our car just let me show you
copy the thing come back to the car just first
of all, save the entirety Okay, now if you
right here consolo like this, look at this.
I'm gonna right here is small console, okay,
console, the log bracket pays the thing Okay,
shop items data, which is coming from where
data Jas Okay, now look at this, I'm gonna
save the entire thing. Let's go and look at
the result. Okay, you're gonna hit F 12. Go
to the console, you can see the data array
for and it carries all the data of the products
that are selected. I'm in data listed on the
shop page. Look at that. It got the description,
it got the ID, image, name, price, etc. So
far, so good, guys. Now guys, let's go back
to our VS code on the main js Okay, so not
major, sorry, Karges. Let's remove the thing
from here. And now what we're going to do
is we're going to come to our if statement
here, okay. Now guys, look at this x can see
this x here. So what does it carry? What is
this x? This x is actually a object. Look
at this. Let me show you. So we're gonna hit
console. Okay, the log, we're gonna say x,
save the thing. So what will happen is this
x will run four times. Why is that? That's
because guys, not four times, so it's going
to run three times. That's because guys look
at the application, local storage. How many
things do we have on the basket? Three things.
Okay. That's what the x will run three times.
Now look at the console can see this one here.
We got the ID and the item. Now guys, can
you see this ID here? i Oh, why something?
I Oh, why? Look at the first three letters
I O Y, according to the ID. Okay, according
to this ID, let's search inside our database.
Look at this. Let's come back here on the
data Jas, and where is the I O Y here? Is
it okay? Can I see this one here? This is
our I O Y. ID. Now look at this guys. What
does this object carry this object carries
or image, it carries the price and it also
carries the name. So do you know what I'm
going to do guys? Using this ID, I'm using
this x ID. I'm going to grab the data from
the data GS and then I'm going to target this
image. Do you see this image here? I'm going
to target this image and then I'm going to
get it inside the source. Let me show you
how I do the thing. So what I'm going to do
is first of all, I'm going to destructure
the X or the Y to a district of x that's because
look at this. Do you see this one here? We
have both the ID and the item. We don't need
the item right now we only need the item okay?
So in order to just Target ID we just destructor
the thing like this, look at this lead curly
bracket Okay, Id comma, then we're gonna write
here which one item Okay, equal to x done.
Now we can freely use the ID, which is coming
from this x okay, next step, guys. We're going
to make a search function Look at this. Let
search. Search equal to So what are we searching
from? We are actually searching from this
variable. Can you see this variable here?
Yeah, I just copied the variable which is
from the data GS, okay, come back here and
then we're going to put it here like this.
Okay? So search equals shop items data, then
we're going to write here a fine, okay? Dot
find bracket, okay? Now inside here, we're
going to make es six arrow function something
like this. Okay? Now you can add anything
you wish, no problem, but let's make it simple
guys. Let's write a why here. Okay, you're
gonna do anything? No problem, guys. Let's
just write why. Okay, now, what are we searching
against? What are we searching against? Let's
see. So look at this ID here, guys. Where
is this coming from? This is actually coming
from the basket. Okay? And where is this wire
coming from? This is coming from the data
GS. Okay, so what do I want, I want to match
this ID with this ID, which means that whatever
ID we have on the basket, we want to match
that with the ID from our database, something
like this. Let me show you. Okay, so we're
going to come here, and then we're going to
write here why that ID is triple equal to
id, this ID is coming from here, which is
from the basket, and this is coming from the
database, which is from that database, okay?
And then what we're going to write this, you're
going to also take me here, or you're going
to make it blank like this. So what do I mean
by this? I mean by this is that if you find
something, then return it. But if you can't
find anything, then just return an empty array
here like this. Okay, so far, so good, guys,
save the thing. Now, guys, we can freely use
the image from the database. Okay, how do
I do it, look at this, come back to the car
js and use this one here. We're gonna come
here and then we're gonna remove the thing.
We're gonna say dollar sign curly bracket,
search dot IMG, save the thing. Let's look
at the result. Okay, the image is huge. You
can see that we got all the images, in order
to make it smaller. Let's come back here.
And then we're gonna see the width here, okay,
with like this equal to, then we're going
to right here. Double quote 100. Like this.
Okay, save the thing. Let's look at the result.
Okay, there we go. Our images got smaller.
Can you see this one here? Okay, why do we
have only three images here? The main reasons
for having three images is that look at look
at your application logo stretch, How many
things did you select from the basket? How
many things do you have on the basket? These
are the products that you selected from the
shop page, you have only three there. So you
have the three, which one is missing? That
casual shirt is missing. Okay, let's go back
to the homepage. Here's the casual shirt.
Okay, so if you select something from here,
let's look at the result. You got now four
images, okay, if you go back here, let's say
that you don't want t shirts. Remove the t
shirt from here. Let's go back here. There
we go. We don't have any casual shirts here.
Okay, so far, so good, guys. Now we also need
to apply some styles and get the data here
so that it looks nice, just like this. Okay,
so in order to do those things, go back to
your VS code. And below the image, we're going
to create another div with a class name details.
Look at this dot details. Okay. Yeah, and
this is class name here. I'm really sorry,
guys, you have to remove this one from here.
It should be only class equal to details.
Okay. Now guys, inside these details, we're
going to have two days and one h3 tag. Let
me show you what I mean by that. Okay, so
we're going to right here dot title minus
price minus x, something like this look, title.
Okay, minus price minus X STEP. Also give
an indent here like this. Okay. Now, let's
go to the next line. And we're going to create
another div which will be named card bottles
like this look, dot card, minus bu TT o n
s tap. On the next line, you're gonna write
h3 tags. Okay, something like this. Now, guys,
was the main reason for creating these three
HTML elements. Let me show you guys. Do you
see this title? Price and the X. Okay, so
if I compare that with the finalized product,
look at this. Do you see this one here? We
have something called casual shirt. We have
the price and we have the cross sign. Okay.
So using this Dave, this is Dave here. Yeah.
Isn't this Dave? We're going to create these
three things together. Okay. Next, we have
something called card buttons. Can you see
this one here? So easing this one, we're going
to create this this this button here along
with the plus minus and the quantity here.
Yeah, so guys, using this one, we're going
to build up this component here. Okay. And
this is price here. We're going to display
the price inside the h3 tag. Okay. So I really
hope guys that you understood why I wrote
the thing. Okay, guys, now let's put some
gap in between them so that it looks nice
and understandable. Now inside the first one
instead, the first day of what we're going
to write here, look at this following with
me guys. Let's give some indentation here
like this. We're going to have two things.
First one is the h4 tag, okay, tab. Next up,
we're going to have icon which you read across
sign. So in order to get the icon just come
over to your icons or get bootstrap.com. And
here we just write here, just a x. Now scroll
to the very bottom. The x is actually here.
Where is it? Here? Is it okay x minus LG.
Click on This one then copy the link. Okay,
let's go back to our cart Jas. Okay. Now,
paste the thing like this. Save the thing.
Now inside this h4, we're going to write a
p tag. Okay, first of all, let's give it some
indentation like this P tab. Now inside here
you're gonna write dollar sign curly bracket
search.net. So where is this name coming from?
This name is actually coming from the data.
Jas, this is name here casual shirt, then
we have official, etc. Okay. I really hope
that you understood how I'm doing this thing.
Okay, save the thing. Now let's do the result.
Okay. If we look at the result, it will look
something like this. Can I see this one? Here?
We are the office shirt. And then we also
have x here. But don't worry, guys. Even though
it looks bad, we're going to use Styles to
make the thing look nice. Okay, just follow
along with me what I'm doing. Let's go back.
By the way guys can see this x here. We're
going to make it red color. So let's do that
right now. So do you see this arm? Where is
it? This is b minus x minus LG copy the thing.
Now let's go back to your main. Where is it
starts? Yes. So guys, you're gonna come back
to your style css at the very bottom, okay,
here, you're gonna write here dot paste. Okay,
then curly bracket. BGC, not BGC. Sorry, this
is going to be color. You're going to read
set it to red color, okay? And then we can
also optionally give some font weight. Okay,
font weight, we can set it to bold. Okay,
do l the same thing now guys, let's look at
the result. Okay? Now you can see that ignore
is that the x is actually red in color. Brilliant
guys. Now let's go back to our VS code after
zooming out. Where is it here on the car chase,
okay, below this p tag, you're going to create
another P tag which will display the price
okay of the single quantity unit. Okay, so
just right here, dollar sign space, dollar
sign curly bracket AG, this dollar sign will
be the currency and this one will be the variable.
Okay. So here we go. Right search dot price.
Okay, this price is also coming from where
it is coming from the data GS, which is here.
Can you see this one here? Yeah, let's go
back here. And now let's look at the result.
Okay, it should look something like this cancer
is one here. We have the office shirt here,
where the price here and then we have the
delete button here as well. So far so good,
guys. Now we're going to style it in a way
that it looks nice. Okay, in order to make
it nice. First of all, let's go back to our
style css not styles here. Sorry. Got HTML.
And guys, do you remember this one here? Shopping
Cart. Copy this thing, okay. Like this. Now
let's go back to our style css and at the
bottom here. Let's create a comment. First
of all, okay, comment like this. We're gonna
write exclamatory sign and then we're going
to hear style. Okay, rules for shopping cart
paid the thing again, done. Now here you're
gonna hear dot paste curly bracket. So guys,
how do they actually do the finalized project?
Okay, how did you do this? I actually use
something called display grid. Okay, this
is a single column. Okay. So that is also
responsive. Look at that. If I hit F to F,
look at this, if I go to the mobile screen,
it is responsive like that. Okay, so how do
they do the thing, I actually use a single
column, and each of this card is 320 pixels
in width. So guys, let's do the same thing
with our project. Okay, so you're gonna come
back to your style css here, you're gonna
write display grid, TG tap. On the next line,
you got igtc, tap, OK, on the repeating I
write one comma y one. Okay. The main reason
for putting one is that we want only one column,
okay, that's what I have put here, one, then
you're gonna write here 320 pixel, okay, by
treating the pixel, I mean that the width
should be at the width of the column should
be 320 pixel. Say the thing guys. Now let's
look at the result. Okay, we can't actually
see any changes unless we see some border
around all these cars, okay, in order to set
the border around these cards so that we can
see it better. Do follow along with me guys.
Just copy the comment from here and put it
here. Okay, so it is going to be style rules
for cart item. Where am I getting the cart
item from? I'm actually getting the cart item
from here you see this one here? So just copy
the thing from here. Let's go back to our
cart HTML not sorry, not here. style css,
okay, come here and then you're gonna hit
dot paste Okay, curly bracket here right here
border. Okay, where's the border border to
px solid red, not Versailles black, or you
can also use that hashtag you can also use
this color here Okay, say the thing. Now guys,
let's look at the result okay, it will look
something like this. Next step guys. We're
going to put this entire thing on the exact
center we're going to have some gapping between
them and do is this point it corner here we're
going to make it rounded Okay, in order to
make those changes just come back to your
shopping cart first of all and then we're
going to right here one second guys. We're
going to right here JC see tab okay justify
content center. Okay, if we look at the result
it has come it has moved to the exact center.
Okay, next up guys. We're gonna give some
gap in between these cars. Can I see this
one here? We have no gaps. Okay, so we're
gonna right here. gap of 15 pixel okay. 15
pixel, say Other thing, let's look at the
result. Okay? There we go, we have to get,
let's make this rounded. Let's make this point
it corners rounded. Okay, in order to make
that thing, just come back to your cart item
here, okay? Then you're going to have border
radius of five pixels. Okay? Five, px, save
the thing. Let's look at the result. There
we go. It looks something like this. Alright
guys, now look at our image here and the content
here. How does it look like it looks like
a column. But we don't want that we want it
to behave like a roll like this. Okay, in
order to solve the issue, do you know what
we're gonna do? You're gonna target which
one, let's come back here. Or we're gonna
target the current HTML, and then we're going
to write a display flex, DF, tap. Save the
thing, guys. Now look at the result. It looks
like our finalize project here you see brilliant
guys, but look at this guys. This is official
$100 and the X. It is not behaving like a
column. Can you see that? But we want to,
but we want it to behave like a row, something
like this. Okay, in order to do that thing,
what we're going to do is we're going to first
of all go back to our main GS sorry, not main,
just Karges okay, just make some mistakes
here. So guys, come back to your card js and
use this one here. This is the class name
by the way guys catch this one here. I made
a small error. My apologies, guys. I it is
not class name. It should be only class. Now
let's fix this one as well. And every time
you see something class name, remove the name,
it should only be class, otherwise, it's not
going to work. Okay, let's copy this thing
guys style minus price minus x. Okay, after
copying the thing, come back to your style
css, by the way, guys can see this one here.
I mistakenly wrote two comments of the same
name. So this is shopping cart here. Yeah,
it should match this one. And this this cart
item here, it should match here. So let's
actually remove this one and write style rules
for cart minus items. Done, guys. Now let's
scroll to the very bottom here, we're going
to add dot paste. Okay, then we're going to
hit curly bracket. Okay, inside here, we're
right, display flex step, save the thing.
Now guys, let's look at the result. It should
look something like this. But guys can see
this one here, this x and these things are
not aligned on the exact center. Okay. So
in order to solve this issue, look at this.
I'm just gonna come back to all my VS code.
Let me just keep it here like this. Okay,
you keep your eyes here. Okay, and then I'm
gonna write the code here, look at this, I'm
gonna use AIC tab, the moment I hit the save,
look at this. They are now aligned on the
exact center right? And next up guys do this
x here. I'm going to put it at the corner
here. In order to do that, we're gonna write
JC SVLK justify content space between same
thing now let's look at the result. Can you
see that? It didn't work? Why didn't it work?
Guys? Let me show you a trick. So in order
to understand something like why a certain
element is not working, always add this border.
Okay to px solid, right? Then you can see
the entire element here. Can you see this
one here? This is the entire element. The
main reason for the X not put coming at the
aim here is that this content here is fixed.
It is locked. Okay? It cannot expand itself.
So in order to make it expand, what we're
going to do is we're going to give you a way,
look at this. We're going to set it a weight
of 195 pixels. Okay? Say the thing. Let's
do the result. There we go. Can you see this
x now expanding here? Brilliant, guys. So
far, so good. Now we don't actually need border
anymore. You can keep it or you can just make
comment legs. Okay, save the thing. There
we go. It looks nice. But guys, look at this
one. This is $300. Then we have the $100.
Here. We don't want it here. We want it to
be here, just like this one can see this one
here. Yeah. So let's make those necessary
changes. Okay, so that it looks like this.
So let's go back to your card. Yes. First
of all, let's expand the thing. Okay. Do you
see this h4 tag? Yeah, we're going to put
here another class here. Okay, class one second
class. name equal to is going to be double
quote, we're going to write your title minus
price. So why did I put both the title minutes
price? That's because this tag actually carries
both the name I mean, the title and the price.
That's why I name it. I named it like this.
So guys, I'm just gonna copy the thing. Let's
go back to our style css, and at the bottom,
I'm gonna write dot paste curly bracket. So
here I'm right display flex, okay. aiic tab
for the Align items center. Okay, and now
let's say the thing let's look at the result.
It should look something like this. But guys,
we don't have any gap in between them. Can
you see that? So in order to put some gap,
let's put gap of 10 pixel inside the title
minus price here is it okay? So we're gonna
actually a gap of how much 10 pixel Okay,
now look at this guys. We have a gap of 10
pixel here, okay, this this price here, we
want to style it in a way that it looks nice,
just like this one. Okay. So follow along
with me guys. So where is this actually located?
Let's first of all, locate that you're gonna
go to your car chase. Okay. Now, where is
it? It's actually here. You can see this one
here. search.com Eyes on the p tag. Yeah.
So we're going to attach a class here. Okay,
look at this. We're gonna write a class. Okay,
equal to double quote is going to be cart
item price. Okay? CART minus item minus price.
Okay, now copy this thing from here. Let's
go back to your start at first and save the
thing. Okay, copy. After copying the thing,
go back to your style css, okay, and at the
bottom, alright, dot paste, okay, curly bracket.
Inside of here you go, right, first of all,
BGC Logan's BGC, tap, okay, you're going to
sell it, select the color, which we specified
to one to control space, okay, if you forgot
the thing like this, we're going to want to
five to nine, then we're going to set the
color to white, something like this. Okay.
There we go. Now, if we look at the result
of a saving, it should look something like
this, right? We're going to apply some padding
and some border area so that it looks nice.
Okay. So in order to do those things, just
come here, and then you're gonna write border
radius of four pixels, something like this.
Okay? Then we're going to apply some padding
of three pixels on the top and bottom and
six pixel on the left and right, something
like this. Let's look at the result guys after
saving. Now look at that. It looks nice. Okay,
let's zoom out. Okay. Next step, guys. This
is buttons here. Yeah. Do you think that this
looks very familiar? Yes, it looks familiar.
If you go to the homepage, we actually imported
this component inside our cart page. Okay.
That's why it looks similar. That's why it
looks identical. So we're not going to write
it. We're just going to copy paste some lines
from our main Jas. Okay, so what you're gonna
do is you're gonna go to your main js where
is it? Means Yes. Okay, then you're going
to open a general shop function. Okay. Now,
where is the div with the class name buttons.
Here, it can see this one here. So just click
on here, and then there's this thread here.
Yeah. So following this thread, you just copy
the entire thing from here. Okay. After copying
the entire thing, just come back to your cart.
Yes. Okay. Next up this this one here, you
can just easily remove the thing because we
copied the same thing, right? Then you're
going to paste it, let's say the thing and
give some indentation here like this. Okay?
So in order to give some indentation, do this,
okay, so you select everything inside the
div, then you're going to hit Tab like this.
Okay? Come here, and you're gonna see the
cut tab like this, it should look something
like this, okay? Or you can also give another
indent here like this. There we go. Save the
thing. Now, let's look at the result. Okay?
Where is it here? Is it okay? There we go.
Can see this one here, we have the plus and
the minus icons, along with the number indicator
here as well, if you click on the plus, or
if you click on the minus is not going to
work. Why is that? That's because look at
this card Chase. Okay, if I close up this
one, we don't have the increment and decrement
function. That's why it's not going to work.
But if you open up this one, if we scroll
down, can you see this one here? The I hit
the minus button, right? It got the decrement
here, and this is here. Where is it? This
is the plus it got the increment here, even
though they got it here. It's still not going
to work. That's because guys, we didn't define
these functions at the bottom. We're going
to do that right now. But before that, do
you see this one here? Yeah, we don't need
this one. Okay, so what you're gonna do is
you're going to remove the thing from here,
okay. And one second, guys, let me make it
a better like this. Give me a second. There
we go. Okay, it should look something like
this. Now, one second that if you scroll up,
do you remember this item here? Yeah, you
can just copy the item which is actually coming
from where this x, where is this x coming
from? This x is coming from the basket. Okay,
just copy the item from here, scroll down
to your here quantity. Okay, this right here,
dollar sign curly bracket paisa thing done,
save it. Now let's look at the result. Now
you can see the number getting shown here
live. So guys, this number here represents
the quantity of the item that you selected.
Okay? But still if you click on the plus and
the minus is not going to work, okay? In order
to make the thing work. Look at these guys.
I'm literally I'm literally gonna go to the
main Jas. Okay, one second. Let me just close
this thing. Zoom out a little bit. Do you
see this increment decrement I'm gonna copy
the thing from here. Okay, after copying the
thing, go back to your card. Yes at the bottom,
okay, paste the entire thing like this, save
it. First of all do this. You just close it
like this. Okay, scroll up, and then you close
it like this. Okay. Also along with these
guys, we also need to get the update otherwise
we can't see the changes on the HTML I mean
on the results screen just copy the update
function. Come back here and then paste the
thing like this. I'm gonna save the thing
you can also fold it like this. And there
we go. Let's look at the result okay after
saving everything on the card JS Okay, so
if everything goes well if you click on the
plus is going to work perfectly fine. Not
only that guys, you can see this one can see
this one here it is we're also working perfectly
fine Look at that. Right click let's click
on the plus it's working let's click on the
minus there we go. It's working perfectly
fine. Okay. All right guys. There's an issue
with our code do is buttons here. Yeah, the
plus sign works to really fight no problem,
but the problem is with the minus, every time
I go and hit a zero, the thing this card doesn't
remove itself automatically. But we want the
thing to remove itself automatically something
like this look, let's say that we have a four
here, okay? Or let's say, I want to remove
this thing. Look at this 3210. You see, it
removed itself automatically, in order to
implement the same system into our project,
the solution guys is very, very, very simple.
Follow along with me, guys, due to this decrement
function here. Yeah, first of all, you're
going to open the thing. Okay? And does this
generate cart items here? Yeah, just copy
the thing. And now, do you see this comment
here? I'm gonna remove the comment, and then
I'm going to paste the thing like this. Okay.
Now look at this. I'm going to save the thing,
mystical result. Okay, this is the, these
are project results. So let's go to 03210.
There we go. It went away automatically. How
is this actually happening? Guys? Let me explain.
Okay, so guys do remember this line here?
Yeah. What is it actually doing? Its main
job is to filter out all the objects which
has an item of zero. So once it's done filtering
out those data, is gonna rerender our cards
using this function here, you see this one
here? It is actually used to re render our
cards. So if I scroll up, where is this actually
coming from? Where is this trigger leading
us to? This is going to lead us to the function
of generate card items, which actually helps
us to generate these cards. You can see this
one here. Yeah. So that's how the mechanics
actually work. Okay, first of all, is going
to remove those unnecessary data, the data,
which has an item of zero, and then is going
to run the function, which helps us to rerender
all the cards. Let me show you a live demo.
Okay. So how much is this five? Let's try
to go to 04321. The next time I hit a minus
here is going to become zero. Once it turns
zero, do you know which line it will run?
The moment it runs zero, this line will run
and then it's going to read render the cars
isn't this one. Okay? That's how the mechanic
actually works. Look at this. If we click
on this one, there we go, the data is gone
at the center, the card is gone as well. So
guys, I really, really, really hope that you
understood how the mechanics actually work.
Okay, let's go back to the home page. And
let's select some products. Okay, so I'm gonna
select these products here like this. There
we go. Okay, let's go back to the cart page.
And now guys, let's compare this with our
finalize project. Okay, look at this. So we
have a price Kennedy's price here. Yeah, this
is the total price of the item that you selected
along with the quantity. Okay, so if you click
on the plus like this, look at this, the quantity
increased along with the price increased as
well. So how do you build a component like
this? Very simple, very easy, guys. Follow
along with me. Okay. So we're going to first
of all, do what we're going to go back to
our card chairs here. Do you see this function,
which is the generic cart items? Yeah, this
one, okay. So we're going to scroll down slowly.
Okay. After the buttons, do you remember this
h3 tag? Yeah, we're going to write the thing
inside here. Okay. So guys, follow along with
me. Let me zoom in a little bit. Okay. So
here, I'm gonna first of all write $1 sign
to represent the currency. Okay. Then we're
going to write $1 sign curly Rec. Inside here.
Do you remember the item guys with item? Here
is the item. Okay? Can you see that? First
of all, copy the thing. Okay, then scroll
down here. Okay. Paste the item here. So what
does the item represent? Let me tell you after
saving the thing, let's look at the result.
Can you see this one here? Yeah, 14, this
number here, this is the quantity, this quantity
is actually getting represented here. This
quantity is getting printed here. But we want
what do we want, we want the quantity to get
multiplied by this number here guarantee this
one here. This is the price of the unit. This
is the price of one unit, we want to multiply
this with the item quantity. And then we will
get the final result here. So in order to
do something like this, let me show you how
to do the thing. Scroll up this one here,
search God price, copy the thing, scroll down
on the item, okay, you're gonna hit a star,
then paste the thing done. Save the thing.
Now, guys, let's look at the result. There
we go. Guys can see this one here? Yeah, this
is the unit price. And this is the quantity,
it got multiplied, and it gave us the result
here. This is the thing that we are expecting.
But here's one thing that we don't expect.
Every time you click on the plus like this.
We want the press to get update, but it is
not updating, right. It's not working perfectly
fine. But everything every time you hit the
minus Can you see that? The minus actually
works, but the plus doesn't work. Why is that
guys? It looks quite strange. In order to
solve the issue. First of all, let's look
at the decryption function one second. Let's
actually close this one like this. Let's look
at the decryption function guys. What are
we doing? Every time we click on the minus
the decryption function runs eventually this
generate cart item also runs. So why is this
important? What does it actually do? This
helps us to rerender our carts with the app
updated data. That's why guys, that's why
only the minus works but not the plus. In
order to solve the issue, look at this very
simple, very easy. Just copy the thing, okay?
folio decrement, open the increment. Okay,
now scroll on guys. Do you see this console
here? Yeah, I'm going to remove the thing,
paste it like this, save the thing is going
to solve or is going to solve our issue. Let's
look at the result guys. Every time you click
on the Plus, there we go. Look at that. It's
working perfectly fine. You see now let's
try to click on the minus there we go. It's
working. Brilliant. Okay. All right, guys.
So first server Next up, this is delete button
here. Yeah, we're going to make a function
named remove item so that every time we click
on this one is going to remove the entire
card here. Okay, so let's go and build that
up. So in order to build that up, go back
to your card GS and below the update, what
we're gonna write, we're gonna write a function,
okay, there, remove item, okay, remove item
is going to be es six arrow function like
this. Okay, now inside here, we're gonna pass
the ID. So why did I pass the ID? Let me tell
you. Okay, so the thing is, how does does?
How will JavaScript exactly know that which
card that you're selecting? OK, all of this
ID in all of these cars has a unique ID, okay?
Using that unique ID, we're going to delete
the thing. Okay, that's why I have included
the ID in that parameter. Next up, guys, we
need to copy this and invoke it in the place
where the X icon is actually select located.
Okay. Do you see this one here? Yeah, title
price minus x. Inside here, you have the icon
here, okay. So on the icon you're gonna hit
on, click OK. On Click equal to double quote,
okay. Pay is the thing invoked here. Next
up, guys, scroll up. Do you see this ID here,
copy the ID scroll down, you're gonna write
here dollar sign, curly bracket Id done. Now,
in order to test whether the thing actually
works or not. You're going to scroll down
here, look at this. Okay? Then you're going
to actually let select it sorry, Selected
Item. Item equal to id. Okay, guys, next up,
we're going to check console, a console log,
we got it selected item like the same thing.
Let's do the result. Okay. So let's hit F
12. Again, let's go to the console. Every
time you click on, let's say the x like this
currency doesn't here, we got the entire HTML
element inside here, which we don't actually
want. We want only the Id only the unique
number here. Can I see this one here? Yeah.
So in order to hire only that, we're going
to address selected item.id only save the
thing, just look at the result. Okay, there
we go. Every time you click on the X Kasetsart.
Here, we can only get the unique ID for which
is actually located for each and every one
of these cards, something like this. You see,
so far. So good, guys. By the way, can you
see this console here? I mean, this this data
here, they're coming from the console. Let's
remove that thing. Okay. So in order to remove
those things, go back to your generic card
items. Okay, here is the console. Let's remove
the thing from here, okay, because it looks
kind of odd. Okay. Once that's done, guys,
let's scroll down to the very bottom here.
Where is it? Here's the console. Okay, let's
make it a comment here. Now, guys, let's look
at the result. Okay? Every time, every time
I click that cross, do you know what will
happen? Every time I click on the cross is
going to remove that object from the local
storage? Let me show you. So if I go back
to the local storage here, where is the item
19. Okay, this is a quantity of 90 Here is
the 19 here, right? Every time I click on
the X, I want to remove this entire object
from here. Okay, in order to do that, we're
going to use something called a filter function.
So let's do the exact same thing. Okay. So
we're gonna right here basket, okay, basket
equal to basket dot filter. Okay. Next step,
I'm going to use a es six arrow function inside
here like this. Okay, now we're gonna write,
you can write anything, no problem in arguments,
but let's keep it simple. Let's write your
X. Okay? So inside the X, what we're going
to target is we're targeting against the ID,
because there's the thing that is only unique,
so we're going to target x.id. So what I'm
doing is that in this x of the filter function,
I'm targeting all of these objects one by
one. And since I targeted the ID here, what
I'm doing is I'm targeting and matching against
all the ID. Okay, so now, let's come back
here and then I'm going to right hit not equal
to selected item.id, which is this one, okay?
Copy this thing and put it here like this.
Okay? So what this will do is that which ever
item you click on the cross, what is going
to do is is going to remove that thing. It's
going to remove that item from the cart and
then it's going to update our basket. Okay,
so it says the upgrade will come to the basket
only but we also want the update to go to
our local storage as well. So in order to
do that, just open up either one of them increment
or decrement be like this. Now scroll down,
you have a line called local storage dot set
item. Copy the thing you don't have to write.
Okay? Just copy the thing, scroll down. Do
you see this remove item here on the function
phase, the thing like this, okay, done. Save
it. Now, guys, let's go and look at the result.
Okay, if you come back here, let's click on
the X. Okay, so what is the number here eight
ways is actually here. Every time you click
on the X, the number and the object actually
goes away. But the object itself, I mean,
the card itself doesn't go away. But it goes
away every time you refresh the page, but
we don't want this behavior, we want it to
update itself automatically. So in order to
do that, what we're gonna do is look at this
is very simple, guys, we're gonna re render
our components, okay, we're gonna re render
all of our cards every time we select the
cross button, okay? So in order to do that,
copy this thing, okay? Copy the thing, scroll
down, and then paste it here like this. Okay,
save the thing. Now, guys, let's look at the
result. Okay? So every time let's say the
casual shirt, I don't need the casual shirt.
So I'm going to hit the X like this. There
we go. It is removing here and reviewing,
removing here at the same time. Let's select
this one like this. There we go, is removing
everything and it's working perfectly fine.
But guys, look at this candidate is on here,
cart is empty. Why is that? That is because
we don't have any data here. Okay, let's go
back. And then let's select something, okay?
Something like this. And now let's go to the
cart page like this. There we go. Okay, let's
test it again. Let's click on here is going
here. And it's removing itself here as well.
So far, so good, guys. Now, guys, let's look
at our file s project, which is here. Can
you see this component here? Yeah, total bill
and the checkout clear cut, we're gonna make
this button. I mean, we're going to make this
component right now, in order to make something
like this follow along with me, guys, we're
going to create a function and we're gonna
name it total amount so that it can calculate
all the total amount of our bill. Okay, so
we're gonna make an ESX error function, let
total amount, okay, equal to is going to be
an ESX error function like this, something
like this. There we go. Okay, now inside here,
we're gonna have two cases. The first case
is when do we have data on the local storage?
And the other cases when we don't have any
data on the local storage? Okay, just like
this one. Let me show you. Just like the generic
cart items, how many cases do we have here?
Two cases. So the first case is when we have
data on the local storage. And the second
case is when we don't have any data on the
local storage, okay? In the same way, we're
going to have two cases instead, the total
amount, okay, so look at this, if, okay, basket,
dot length is not equal to zero, run this
code, else, we're just gonna return the thing.
So why else return we mean that don't do anything,
just stop the process. Okay. Next up, guys,
inside this curly bracket, we're going to
write let em out. Okay? amount is equal to,
we're going to target the basket, and we're
gonna map the thing. Okay, look at this. We're
gonna write basket dot map. Okay. So why am
I actually mapping the thing? Now, guys, let
me tell you the main reasons for mapping the
thing. Okay, the main reason for mapping this
thing? I mean, the mapping the basket is that
look at this. So if I go back to the local
storage here, yeah, look at this. Do you see
it here and use the item here? We already
have the item. Okay, we already have the item,
but we don't have the price. So using this
ID, can you see this on here? What is this?
I owe ya, right? Using this ID, we're going
to go and search inside our data. Gs where's
our data? Yes, our data js is here, isn't
that ID, which is the I O Y key and this is
one here. Using this ID, we're going to search
inside our data Jas, and then we're going
to grab the price from there. Once we grabbed
the price. From there, we're going to multiply
that without item so that we can get the total
price. I really, really, really hope that
you understood what I mean by that. Now I'm
going to show you the live sample. Okay. So
in the car GS, look at this, I'm going to
come here and then I'm right here bracket,
okay. I'm gonna write anything, no problem,
but let's keep it simple. We're gonna write
here es six error function, and then let's
pass X, okay. Now curly bracket. Now you can
you can also destructure the X. How do you
destructure the X and how does it happen?
Look at this. This is ID and the item, you
can separate the thing like this look, we're
going to come here and then we're going to
write here let okay? Let curly bracket equal
to is going to be x okay, now come here and
then write it m comma ID. Okay? Save the thing.
Now on the next line guys. What we're going
to do is using this ID, we're going to search
inside our database. So guys, we don't have
to write anything if you recall, if you go
to the one second guys, if you go to the Generate
cart items, you can easily get the function
here do use this search function here. Yeah,
just copy the thing because it already exists
there, we don't have to write it again, copy
the search function, then you're gonna just
close the thing there, scroll down to your
total amount function, okay? Just paste the
thing here like this. Okay, so what is it
actually doing? It is using the ID to match
against the database. Okay, for an example,
look at this, okay, one second. For an example.
Look at its i o y thing, okay? It is actually
getting stored inside, where is it? It's actually
getting stored inside this ID. Okay? So this
search, what it will do is, is going to search
this ID against the idea of the local, I'm
in the, I'm in the database, okay? Which is
actually here. Okay. I really, really, really
hope that you understood what do I mean by
this line? Okay, next up, what we're gonna
do is we're going to return look at this,
you're going to return the item. Okay? By
the way, let me actually show you what the
item means. Okay. So if you go back to local
storage here, this item here two to three,
yeah, that's the item. And then we have something
called Search dot price. Look at this. So
you just multiply the thing like this, okay,
multiply search dot price. This price is actually
coming from here. You see this one here? Okay,
so now look at this guys. I'm going to console
log the thing so that you can see it better.
Okay? So in order to console log, the thing,
look at this, I'm right here console. Okay,
dot log. Sorry, guys, not here. Cut the thing
from here. And this is L statement before
the else statement here. Okay, paste the thing,
bracket. And then do use this amount here.
Yeah, copy the amount, put it here. Like they
save the thing. Now, guys, let's do the result.
Okay. By the way, guys, it will actually not
work because you have to invoke it. So copy
the thing, scroll down and put it here like
this. Okay, bracket. Done. Save the thing.
Let's look at the result, guys. Now let's
go to the console. Can you see this one here?
200 607 75. So how is this coming? This is
actually the cap x. This is actually the calculation
of this one's can see this one here. The 600
is here. The 600 is here. 7575 200 200. Okay,
so we got all the all the total prices have
individual cards inside this array here. Do
you know what I'm going to do next? I'm going
to add all the numbers together. In order
to do that, what we're going to do is use
this here, yeah, remove the semicolon and
put a dot Okay, we're gonna use the reduce
function, okay, reduce the negative bracket,
you're gonna hit es six arrow function, okay,
something like this. Then you're gonna write
hit X comma Y. Okay. Next up, guys, you add
the x and y, what does the X and Y means let
me tell you, the x is the the X guys is the
previous number, and y is the next number.
So what is doing is by x&y, I mean that add
these two numbers and then get the next one.
So that's why I wrote here, x comma y and
then I have to write x plus y, and then comma,
I want this thing to start from zero. That's
why I'm gonna give it a zero here. Okay? See
the thing. Now guys, let's look at the result.
There we go. Can you see this one here, it
gave us the calculation, the total calculation
that we were searching for. So guys, our function
is complete. Now we're going to implement
that so that it looks something like this.
Okay? In order to make something like this,
let's go back to our VS code. Let's guys,
do you see this one here? Either comment or
remove the thing. Okay, I'm gonna comment
a thing. And then I'm gonna scroll to the
very top here, this label here. Yeah, copy
the thing there, scroll down to your total
amount function below this comment here, paste
the thing, okay, then you go right hit dot
innerHTML equal to, we're going to use a template
literal. So you're going to hit backtick.
And here you can write, then here you can
write h2 tab. Okay, then guys, you're gonna
have total, okay, Bill coloane. You're gonna
have dollar sign for the currency and then
you're gonna write dollar sign, curly bracket
amount, okay? This amount is actually coming
from here. You see this one here? See the
thing guys now guys, let's do the result.
Okay, there we go. We got it. We have the
total bill here. Can you see this one here?
Brilliant guys. Next step, what we're going
to do is we're going to have two buttons.
One second guys do is checkout and the clear
Cart button. Yeah, we're going to build these
two buttons here inside here. So let's go
and make those things. So what you're gonna
do is below the h2 tag, you're gonna make
a button Okay, look at this video TT o n.
Okay button with a class named checkout. Look
at this dot C, H, E C K, O ut checkout cap.
Guys Guys is going to be class not a class
name. So remove the name from here. Only keep
the class okay. Now inside here we're going
to write check out c h e CK or yearly check
out that save the thing. And below this button
we're going to have another button with a
class name remove all look at this. Bu TT
o n dot remove. Oh, okay tab. Now again guys
is going to be class not class name. Remove
the name from here save the thing. And also
we need to right here clear card something
like this, save the thing. Let's look at his
own case, it should look something like this.
It is not styled. Let's start the thing. Okay.
First of all guys, copy the checkout from
here. Now guys, you're gonna go to your style
css. And now guys, you're gonna select for
a specific selector that we already selected.
And we already build that. Okay, so let me
just search for the thing. It's actually the
homework guys can see this one here. Yeah.
So you don't have to write all the styles
to discuss follow along with me. Just put
a comma here. Okay, and then dot paste done.
Now, guys, let's look at the result. It should
look something like this. Can you see that?
Yeah, in the same way, we're going to style
the clear Card button as well. Follow along
with me guys. Come back here on your card,
GS, copy the remove all come back to your
style, CSS, comma, okay, and then dot paste
done, save the thing. Let's look at the result.
There we go. You see much better. But guys,
I want the thing to be in green color, just
like this one. And I want the thing to be
red color. So in order to do those things,
follow along with me, copy the checkout. Okay,
scroll down and put it here like this dot
paste, filled record, you can right here.
VGC tab is going to be which color green,
like they say the thing and remove all right,
copy that thing. Scroll down, or dot paste
curly bracket, color or sorry, BGC. Tab is
going to be red. There we go save the thing.
Now let's look at the result. Okay, there
we go. Guys. It looks just like our finalize
product here. Can I see this one here? It
looks totally identical. Next up, guys. Guys,
it looks nice. But look at this. Here's a
problem. Every time you click on the plus,
look at this, this number I mean this quantity
and the price actually increases. But can
you see this one here? It is not updating
itself. So guys, in order to update this thing,
I mean, this one is very simple solution is
very simple. Guys, just come over here and
to your cart. Yes. Do you remember the total
amount? Copy this thing? Okay. And then guys,
where's your update function? One thing, let
me just fold the thing like this, where's
your update function is actually here. Can
I see this one here? Just open the thing.
And then below the calculation function, you
just invoke the thing here like this. There
we go. Done. Okay. Now, guys, let's look at
the result. Okay, every time. This is the
result page, okay, every time you click on
the plus like this, look at that. It's updating
itself live. It is working perfectly fine.
Okay, brilliant. Now, guys, here's actually
another issue here. Look at this business.
29. Here. Yeah, 2900. Actually, this 100 Every
time I click on the cross like this, that's
going away. But it's not actually upgrading
itself. There was $100 there. But now it should
be 2800. But it's not updating itself automatically
every time you hit the refresh like this,
only then it refreshes. I mean, only then
it updates updates itself, there is the behavior
that we don't want in order to fix that. Where
is the function that removes that item? It
is actually remove it right? So copy this
one, I will copy the entire thing. Open up
this one. And do you see this one? Generic
cart items below this one, invoke it like
this, save the thing. Let's look at the result.
Okay? So look at this, how much is this 1500
Okay, 2800. Every time you click on the cross,
it goes away at the same time, it updates
the thing here as well. So guys is working
perfectly fine. Now guys, let's go back to
the homepage. Let's select some data. Okay,
I mean, let's select some products from here.
Let's go back to the cart page here. The next
feature that I'm going to build is the clear
cart feature. Okay, every time we click on
this one is going to first of all remove the
entire thing at the same time. Do you see
this local storage guys one second. On the
local storage we also want the entire thing
to get removed as well. So in order to build
that follow along with me guys, come back
to your car JS Okay, and below the remove
item or anywhere okay, you can write the function
anywhere you like. We're going to right here
clear car, okay, lead clear car, okay, it's
gonna be an ES six arrow function like this.
Okay, next up guys look at this, we're going
to actually a basket equal to we're going
to make an empty array it means that whatever
data we have on the basket, remove the thing.
Okay, so guys, once we are done removing all
the items from the basket, we also need to
re render the cards in order to re render
the screen. This is generic card items here,
copy the thing scroll down and put it here
like this. Okay, done. Next step guys. We
also need to update the local storage as well.
So in order to update the local storage, just
open the decrement or the increment lights
Okay, do you see this one here? Yeah, just
copy the thing from here. There are close
the thing scroll down on the clear car Okay,
paste the thing here like this and save the
thing. Now guys, we need to invoke the clear
cart as well copy the thing scroll down do
is this total amount here. Open it Okay, so
where's your remove all it is here can see
this one here, this clear Cart button. So
guys, what we're gonna do is we're gonna right
here on click OK, on click equal to double
quote. Then we We're going to invoke the clear
cut function here. There we go save the thing,
guys. Now, guys, let's go and test our result.
This is the result screen, every time you
click on one second, let me also open up a
local storage here like this. So we have some
data on the local storage, we have some build
here, and we have some cards here. Okay, every
time we click on a clear card is going to
remove everything, look at that the data is
gone. And the cart, I mean, and the cart page
is gone. Along with the price and the buttons,
we have only one but back to Home button.
Using this one, we can just go back and we
can select some products like this. There
we go. Let's select some products here. Let's
go back to our cart page. And now let's go
and select this one like this, look at that,
it's working perfectly fine. Okay, let's click
on the cross fine like this is removing that
thing. At the same time. If you click on the
clear cut, it removes everything like that
brilliant. On the far less project, you can
see that we have in total 12 product cards.
So what we're going to do is we're going to
add the other images and data into our project
here. But before doing that, we have some
problem with our code here, which we need
to fix. The first problem is with the nav
bar, it is not aligned properly on the Y axis.
Let me show you what I mean by that. Okay,
so I'm just gonna go back to the code on the
style css, and then what I'm gonna do is use
this navbar here, I'm just going to comment
this code. Okay, I'm gonna save it. Now let's
look at the result. Okay, can you see that
the clothing store and the icon, they are
not aligned on the y axis on the center. So
if you want to fix that, you just gonna come
here and then you're right, AIC tab. Okay,
save the thing. Now let's look at the result.
Can you see that nurse aligned properly, okay,
so I'm going to bring this code back, save
it, there we go. The second problem is in
the cart page. But before going there, first
of all, make sure that you have some products
selected here. And then you're gonna go to
the cart page. Okay. Now, this is number here.
How many quantity do we have on the basket
enroll? We have 24. And now let's do this.
Okay, so I'm going to remove this one. Okay.
So how much quantity is in this inside this
card? It has just five. Okay, so it is 24.
If I'm minus five, I'm 24. How much is it
is going to be 19. So let's remove the thing.
Okay, every time I remove it, it should have
been 19. But it's not doing the subtraction
is going to do the subtraction every time
I refresh the page like that. There we go.
But this is the behavior that we don't want.
So if you want to fix that, where is this
problem situated? Let's find that first. Okay.
The problem is with the function named remove
item, let me show you where it is. So what
you're gonna do is you're gonna go to VS code,
and then you're gonna go to card GS. Then
here is your function remove item, you're
going to open up this one. And then you're
going to scroll up there is this calculation
function here. Just copy the thing and then
put it here like this. Okay, save the thing.
Now let's look at the result. Okay, so now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna remove
this one, okay, how much quantity is here
is five. So how much is here? 19. So 19 minus
five, it should be 14. Let's click on this
one. Let's see the result. Okay, there we
go is working perfectly fine. So our problem
is solved. Let's look at the third problem.
It is here on the clear card. Every time I
click on this one, what do I want? I want
the basket to get zero. It but it doesn't
happen. Let me show you what I mean by that.
Okay, so I'm going to click on Clear card.
Now look at that. It's still 14, but it should
be zero. If a refresher thing, only then is
going to be zero. So guys, the problem is
situated in a function named clear cart. Let's
go find it and fix that. Okay, so I'm going
to go back to VS code, and it is called Clear
cart this here. Do you remember this one calculation,
just copy the thing and put it here like this.
Okay, save it. Now let's look at the result.
Okay. So in order to look at the result, we
have to go back to home, and then we have
to select some items. Okay, just like this.
Now, let's go back. How many items can you
see here? It's a, let's click on clear cut.
There we go. It's now back to zero. Perfect.
Problem solved. All right, guys. Now let's
go back to our VS code, and then scroll to
the very top. Do you remember this function
here, generic card items, open up this one.
And then do you see this search dot Image
Search dot name and search dot price? What
I realized is that you can D structure this
thing and make it shorter. Let me show you
what I mean by that. Okay, so I'm gonna come
here and then I'm gonna right here lead clearly
record high image, comma, name, comma, and
what was the last thing is price. So I'm going
to put the price here like this equal to the
search, okay, copy that, put it here like
this. There we go. Now we don't have right
search dot image anymore. Okay, we can remove
that portion from here like this. Okay, there
we go. Done. Save the thing. Now let's look
at the result. We're gonna get the exact same
result. Okay, to see the result let me just
click some products from here. And then let's
go to the cart page like that. There we go.
You see, there we go. You see we got the exact
same results. And by the way, guys, what is
this called? The search is an object right?
So this is called destructuring, and object.
All right, guys. Now it's time to add the
other product cards inside our project. Before
doing anything, first of all, we have to to
the local storage, okay, just right click
inspect, and then you're gonna go to your
application, wait a second, let me open up
this one, we're gonna go to Application, the
local storage, okay, so now we have to delete
it. So you're gonna click on here, and then
you're gonna do the thing. Okay, next up,
I'm gonna go to my GitHub, I'm going to provide
the link of this GitHub repository in the
description down below. Okay, so if you come
here, then you can realize that it has three
branches. We are on the main branch on the
main branch, we have the entire source code,
okay, we started from the starter files, and
this is product images here. I'm going to
click on this branch here. And then what does
this branch carry? Let me show you inside
the images, it got all the other 12 images.
Okay. So if I come back here, we have also
something called data. Jas, if I open up this
one, then it carries all the data of our product
cards. So do you see this data here? Yeah,
all the data are actually inside this data.
JS. So what we're going to do right now is
we're going to download this thing. Okay?
So let's click on the code, download zip.
Okay. So guys, once it downloads, open the
thing and then you're going to go back to
your Dexter, okay, then what you're going
to do is you're going to extract it outside
like this. Okay, next up, go inside here.
So what do we have inside there? We just have
a folder and a file called dlgs. Okay, so
what we're gonna do is we're going to extract
it outside like this. Okay, there we go. Alright,
guys. So now we're going to extract both the
images and the data inside our project folder
like this, look at that. Okay, then guys,
you're gonna find a message like this, replace
the files in this nation's so you're gonna
click OK, like this. So what it's going to
do is, it's going to remove the duplicate
files from our project. Now we can delete
this one, no problem. Now, let's go back to
our VS code, okay, now you can realize that
we have images, how many images are here,
12 images, okay. And then we also have a file
called Data GS. So come here, and what you're
going to do is, look at this, do you see this
data here, the data is inside a array here,
you see this one array, so come here, and
then you're going to close it like this, copy
the entire thing. Now you're what you're gonna
do is you're gonna go to data, GS, which is
actually situated inside your source, okay,
come here and go to the top, select from here
to the very bottom, and then paste the code
that you copied from the file. Okay, so now
look at this, we have all of our data stored
inside this variable. Now say the thing. And
now come here, and what you're gonna do is
you're going to right click, delete this one.
Okay? This is coming from the GitHub. Okay?
Now, guys, after saving the code, let's go
look at the result. Okay, our result will
look something like this. Look at that we
have how many cards in total, we have 12 product
cards in total. But guys, there are some design
problems with our cards. Let's look at this
one. This is border here. And do you see the
image they're overlapping with each other
here? Can you see that it looks odd, we're
going to fix that. At the same time. Look
at these guys, we don't have any gap at the
bottom, just like the finalist project, look
at that, we have a gap here. So let's go and
implement those things. So let's go back to
our VS code on the style css, then you're
going to find that selector with the class
name shop. Okay, then what you're gonna do
is you're gonna right here in between the
pixel tab, there we go save the thing. Now
let's look at the result, it will look something
like this on our finalized project. But guys,
if you want to adjust the gap, you can do
it as well. So let's come back here. And you
can also put here 50 pixel like this, save
the thing. Let's look at the result. Now look
at that we have a big gap here. Next up, let's
go fix the border and the images. How do you
do that? Very simple, very easy. Go back to
your VS code. So now you're going to find
for a selector called dot item, which is actually
here, can you see that? We have the image
inside the selector. So how do you select
the image from this selector is very simple.
Look at that. You're going to right here dot
item, okay, then I m g curly bracket done.
Now inside here, what we're going to write
is we're going to say with 100%. Okay, with
100%. Let's say the thing there. Let's look
at the result. There we go. Now, can you see
that the border and the image are not overlapping
with each other. But guys, there's another
problem. If I zoom in like this, look at that.
Can you see that? Do you see this corner here?
Yeah, it's pointy corner. But actually, our
border is rounded. So in order to adjust that,
what we're going to do is we're going to go
back here, and we're going to place a border
radius, okay? Border Radius. Okay, radius,
but before putting any value, guys, let me
show you something. Okay. So we want to make
this thing, rounded here. And here. We don't
want the thing to round it here. And here.
So how do you do this? Let me show you guys.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to come
back here, and we're going to put to pixel
first to pixel again, then 00. So what do
I mean by this, this is the top left corner.
This is the top right corner, this is the
bottom left and bottom right corner values,
save the thing. Let us look at the result.
Now guys, you can see that this thing got
rounded and this one as well but not the bottom
left and the bottom right, perfect. With that
our project is complete. I really, really,
really hope that you learned a lot from this
tutorial. If you liked the video, give a like
share it with a friend and feel free to subscribe
till then take care and I'll see you in the
next video.